हेलो
एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल तो पहले मुझे यह बता दीजिए सबको मेरी
आवाज सुनाई दे रही है लाउड एंड क्लियर
नो
स्केलेटन ज्यादा डिफरेंस नहीं
होगा कि बग बाउंट कोर्स में आपने जो
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग फेज कवर किया होगा और
जो हम कवर करने वाले हैं उसमें ज्यादा
डिफरेंस नहीं होगा टूल्स का उन सबका हो
सकता है कुछ टूल्स में एक्स्ट्रा बता दूं
या कम बता दूं लेकिन ज्यादा डिफरेंस नहीं
हुआ क्योंकि इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग स्टेप सेम
ही रहता है लगभग लेकिन उसके बाद जो फेज
स्टार्ट होगा हमारा जिसमें हम सिस्टम
हैकिंग पर ट्रांसफर करेंगे अपने आपको
पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के बाद सेक्शन
टू हमारा आएगा एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
देन उसके बाद हम अपनी एक्चुअल हैकिंग
स्टार्ट करेंगे फुल सीटीएफ के साथ और फुल
कांसेप्चुअल प्लस प्रैक्टिकल दोनों के
दोनों तो वो और भी ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग
रहेगा लेकिन यह क्या है कि इसमें बहुत
सारे स्टूडेंट्स ऐसे हैं जो बिल्कुल ही
जीरो से आए हमारे पास और जो जिन्होने जीरो
से स्टार्ट किया है तो इसलिए तो मैं भी
एटलीस्ट 100 तो हो जानी चाहिए
ना एक्चुअल वॉल्यूम सही है कोई इशू नहीं
है आपको अपनी साइड से वॉल्यूम को बढ़ाना
चाहिए या नेटवर्क स्ट्रांग रखना चाहिए
मेरी तरफ से वॉल्यूम का कोई इशू नहीं
है शर्मा जी लैब सेटअप के लिए मैंने बोला
था कि आपको बीएम वेर को इंस्टॉल करना है
उसमें काली नेक्स या पैरेट ओस या दोनों को
आपने सेटअप करना है और सेटअप करने के लिए
मैंने आपको बताया था कहां पर सेटअप करना
है यह टास्क था आपका और बहुत लोगों ने अभी
तक नहीं किया है
स
इट्स ओके अगर आपके पास कोई भी एक ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम आपने इंस्टॉल कर लिया तो कोई जरूरत
नहीं
है प्लीज बताइए अगर ऑडियो इशू है तो जल्दी
से बताइए कोस स्टार्ट क्लास स्टार्ट करने
से
पहले और एक और इंपॉर्टेंट चीज यह है कि
अभी जैसे जैसे हम आगे बढ़ेंगे तो हमारी जो
स्टेप्स है जैसे कि डीप डीप स्टेप्स होंगे
तो उसमें हम डीप स्टेप की तरह से ही हम
क्या करेंगे उसको इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
करेंगे जैसे कि जो थर्ड क्लास है हमारी
लेकिन ये भी पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग है
लेकिन इसमें क्या है कि हम थोड़ा सा और
ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करेंगे जैसे कि
कुछ टूल्स यूज करेंगे ज्यादा से ज्यादा से
ज्यादा टूल्स में आपको बताने की कोशिश
करूंगा जितने मैं बता सकता हूं क्योंकि
डीप रिकन जो मैंने अपने सिलेबस में मेंशन
किया था उस पर्पस से बताऊंगा अदर वाइज मैं
पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग इस क्लास में
खत्म करके नेक्स्ट क्लास में एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करवा सकता था लेकिन
मेरा ये मोटो नहीं है आपको ज्यादा से
ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन मेरे पास हम आपको देने
की कोशिश
करूंगा तो ओके 79 है इट्स ओके तो क्लास
स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं आपको एक चीज बता
देता हूं कि अभी क्लास के स्टार्टिंग में
बता दूंगा और मैं एंड में भी बता
दूंगा मैंने आप लोगों के लिए सोचा है कि
आप लोगों से डाउट्स कैसे लेने क्योंकि आप
लोगों के बहुत सारे डाउट्स हो सकते हैं
रिलेटेड टू योर कांसेप्ट कि सर मेरे
डाउट्स है क्योंकि लाइव क्लास के दौरान
मेरा ध्यान क्या ज्यादातर पढ़ाने में रहता
है और आपके चैट सेक्शन को कई बार मैं नहीं
देख पाता जिसमें क्या कि आपके कुछ डाउट्स
रहते हैं या कुछ स्टूडेंट्स के डाउट्स
आपके पहले होते हैं वह पूछ चुका होता है
लेकिन उसको रिप्लाई नहीं मिलता तो व क्लास
छोड़कर जा चुके होते हैं तो उनका सलूशन
मेरे पास है आप लोग एक काम कीजिए अगर आपको
किसी भी कांसेप्ट से रिलेटेड डाउट मिलता
है रिलेटेड टू प्रेजेंट कांसेप्ट या जो
मैं क्लासेस करवा चुका हूं या आपको लगता
है कि यह डाउट्स फ्यूचर क्लासेस के लिए भी
है तो प्लीज आप एक काम कीजिए जैसे ही
क्लास एंड हो जाती है क्लास एंड होने के
बावजूद क्या होता है कि आपकी जो
स्ट्रीमिंग है स्ट्रीम वीडियो क्या है
वीडियो रिकॉर्डिंग आपकी लेबल रहती है तो
वहां पर क्या होता है कि लाइक लाइक और
कमेंट तो करते हो तो वहां पर आपको क्या
करना है कमेंट सेक्शन में अपना डाउट पूछ
सकते हो उस कमेंट क्योंकि मैं हर रोज आपके
जितने क्लास वन से लेर क्लास टू अभी तक जो
दो ही क्लास हुई दोनों क्लास की मैं हर
रोज न्यूस्ट जो कमेंट है उसको मैं रीड
करता हूं कि किसी ने वहां पर कुछ ऐसा
कमेंट तो नहीं है जिसको कुछ मतलब अच्छा
नहीं लगा तो उसी तरीके से हम क्या करते
हैं सो मैंने सोचा है कि क्या करने का
वहां पर आपको क्या करना है कमेंट सेक्शन
में अपना कंप्लीट डाउट कि आपको फुल एक जो
आपको पूछना जो लगता है कि आपको आपका यह
सवाल है मुझसे रिलेटेड टू योर कांसेप्ट
रिलेटेड टू दिस कोर्स य जो भी मैं आपको
पढ़ा रहा हूं उसको आप कमेंट में अपना नाम
मेंशन कर सकते हो आई एम सोन सो एंड
क्योंकि आपकी आईडी से मैं पहचान नहीं कर
पाऊंगा लेकिन डेफिनेटली आपका नाम वहां पर
मेंशन करके फिर यह पूछ सकते हो कि सर मेरा
यह डाउट है प्लीज एक्सप्लेन इन नेक्स्ट
सेशन या प्लीज क्लियर आउट तो अगर मुझे ऐसा
लगेगा वे डाउट्स की मैं लिस्ट क्या करूंगा
अपने बुक में बना के रखूंगा और इवन आपके
ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट डाउट्स होंगे मुझे लगता
है कि सबके लिए इंटरेस्टिंग डाउट्स हैं तो
उन डाउट्स को मैं क्या करू
एक स्लाइड में मेंशन करके रखूंगा कि दज आर
द डाउट्स अगर आपका डाउट ऐसा है जो अभी
प्रेजेंट क्लास जो प्रेजेंट क्लास चल रही
है प्रीवियस क्लास होगी उससे रिलेटेड है
तो उस डाउट को जैसे ही नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी
अपकमिंग क्लास होगी उसमें सबसे पहले उस
डाउट को क्लियर किया जाएगा उस डाउट के ऊपर
डिस्कस किया जाएगा अगर आपका डाउट ऐसा है
कि जिसको मैं अपकमिंग क्लास में पढ़ाने
वाला हूं तो मैं उस डाउट को क्या करूंगा
पेंडिंग रखूंगा और जैसे ही
वो डाउट का टन आएगा तो उस डाउट को
ड्यूरिंग सेशन में आपको क्लियर कर दूंगा
तब तक हम उस डाउट को क्या करेंगे अपनी
लिस्ट में मेंशन करके रखेंगे तब तक उस
डाउट को क्लियर नहीं करेंगे तो मे बी एक
बेटर वे है आपसे कम्युनिकेट करने का तीसरी
क्या चीज है कि अगर मुझे लगता है कि आपके
डाउट्स कमेंट सेक्शन के थ्रू क्लियर नहीं
हो पा रहे या हमारी य जो स्ट्रीमिंग है
इसके थ्रू क्लियर नहीं हो पा रहे तो फिर
मैं उन डाउट्स की लिस्ट बनाऊंगा उन
स्टूडेंट्स की एक लिस्ट बनाऊंगा और जिस
आईडी से व कमेंट आया है उस आईडी को मैं
मेंशन करके हम उनकी गल मीट एक मीटिंग ले
लेंगे और डिस्कस कर लेंगे तो एवरीवन एग्री
विद
मी प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए एवरीवन एग्री विद
मी मे भी दिस इ गुड आईडिया
क्योंकि एक कोर्स को हम कोर्स की तरह
पढ़ेंगे मान के चलिए कि यह
youtube2 कोर्स की तरह ही इसको ट्रीट किया
जाएगा उसी तरह ही आपको कंटेंट डिलीवर किया
जाएगा उसी तरह ही आपके डाउट लिए जाएंगे
लेकिन हमारा मीडियम अलग है क्योंकि हम एक
दूस अगर हम डेली डेली ग मीट ट्राई भी
करेंगे तो इतने स्टूडेंट्स हैं
[संगीत]
नहीं होंगे लेकिन आएंगे बारबार डिस्टर्ब
करेंगे तो दिस इज द वे जिसको हम ऐसे कर
सकते
हैं तो यह एक अप्रोच है ट्राई करते हैं और
अगर आप लोगों को अच्छा लगेगा तो कंटिन्यू
करेंगे अच्छा नहीं लगे तो उसका अल्टरनेट
वे ढूंढेंगे लेकिन आपके डाउट्स डेफिनेटली
क्लियर किए जाएंगे कोर्स के दौरान इसकी
चिंता करने की आपको जरूरत नहीं है मुझे तो
अच्छा ऑप्शन लगा कि ट सेक्शन प्रोवाइड कर
रहा तो उस कमेंट सेक्शन को उल्टी सीधी
कमेंट करने की बजाय उसको डाउट सेशन ही
क्यों ना मान ले वहां पर डाउट रखो और उनको
वहां से हम डिस्कस करेंगे सो दैट कि इन
फ्यूचर में कोई भी इन वीडियोस को देखेगा
तो अगर उसका कोई सेम डाउट होगा तो क्लियर
हो जाएगा चलो हम क्लास को स्टैंड करते हैं
और सॉरी क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं तो मे
भी
86 हो जाएंगे 100 आई होप लेकिन
अगर क्लास आगे बढ़ते बढ़ते अगर आप अपनी
काउंटिंग को कम करोगे तो मेरे लिए
डिमोटिवेशन हैय ओबवियसली है कि एक 50000
या 60000 के कोर्स को अगर मैं फ्री में
पढ़ा रहा हूं और मेरे पास ऑडियंस नहीं है
मान के चलिए अगर मेरे पास ऑडियंस नहीं है
जहां पर लाइव नहीं लाइव क्लासेस में
स्टूडेंट्स नहीं है और उसके बाद जो मेरी
रिकॉर्डिंग्स है जो हमेशा लाइव बेसिस पे
डिलीवर की जा रही है टाइमली अपलोड हो रही
है अगर उस पे व्यू नहीं है तो व्हाट कैन
आई डू यार सोचिए मेरे बारे में तो सोचिए
कि मैं इतनी मेहनत कर रहा हूं आप मेरे को
रिस्पांस जीरो दोगे
तो मुझे तो मजा नहीं आएगा
ना मैं तो फिर नहीं कर पाऊंगा आप लोगों के
लिए सेशन डिलीवरी कोर्स मैं डिले करूंगा
फिर जहां पर कोर्स फोर मंथ के ड्यूरेशन
में कंप्लीट होगा वहां पर कोर्स वन ईयर
में कंप्लीट होगा नो प्रॉब्लम उसके लिए
फिर आपको कमेंट सेक्शन में जो भी करना है
कर
लीजिए ओके चलो क्लास स्टार्ट करते
हैं अभी थोड़ा सा हम इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
जो स्टेज है हमारी पिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
चल रही है
प्लीज कीप इन माइंड कि अभी तक हमने एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग को स्टार्ट नहीं किया
है हम अभी तक क्या है पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग स्टेज में है अभी उसमें हम क्या
करेंगे थोड़े से और डीप में जाके ज्यादा
से ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर करने की कोशिश
करेंगे कुछ रेलीवेंट टॉपिक्स हैं जो
थोरेट्स है उनको मैं आज की स्लाइड्स में
और कुछ और स्लाइड्स में क्लियर करूंगा
लेकिन यहां पर हम आने वाले टाइम में बहुत
सारे टूल्स हैं जिनके बारे में डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं जैसे कि सडन है जैसे कि वे
बैक यूआरएल है दे बहुत सारे ऑटोमेशन टूल्स
है जिनके बारे में डिस्कशन करेंगे अभी इन
अपकमिंग क्लासेस में तो प्लीज डोंट मिस
एनी क्लास कि आपको जिससे लॉस हो ओके प्लीज
डोंट मिस एनी क्लास आई
रिक्वेस्ट
चलो अभी बात करते हैं हम फुट प्रिंटिंग
थ्रो वेब सर्विसेस ओके थ्रू वेब सर्विसेस
यू कैन एक्सट्रैक्ट वैरायटी ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन
अबाउट योर टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन ओके वेब
सर्विसेस के थ्रू आप लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन
बहुत तरह की इंफॉर्मेशन को क्या कर सकते
हो गैदर कर सकते हो किसी भी टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बारे में अब मेरा वेब
सर्विसेस से मतलब क्या है सोशल नेटवर्किंग
साइट्स पीपल सर्च सर्विसेस अलर्टिंग
सर्विसेस फाइनेंशियल सर्विसेस एंड जॉब
साइट्स एक्सेट्रा ऑल दीज साइट्स या ऑल दीज
वेब सर्विसेस प्रोवाइड इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट ए
टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यू कैन एक्स्ट क्रिटिकल
इंफॉर्मेशन सच एज टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
डोमेन सब डोमेन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स
जियोग्राफिक लोकेशंस एंप्लॉई डिटेल्स
ईमेल्स फाइनेंशियल इंफॉर्मेशन
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर डिटेल्स हिडन वेब पेजेस
एंड कंटेंट्स एटस यह सारी की सारी
क्रिटिकल इंफॉर्मेशन आप स इन वेब सर्विसेस
के थ्रू फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हो जस्ट सेक
गाइस ओके अभी बात करते हैं यूजिंग दिस
इंफॉर्मेशन यू कैन बिल्ड ए अटैकिंग
स्ट्रेटजी टू ब्रेक इनटू द टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन नेटवर्क एंड कैन कैरी आउट
अदर टाइप्स ऑफ एडवांस सिस्टम अटैक्स अभी
जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन आप जो मेंशन अबोव मेंशन
इंफॉर्मेशन है उस इंफॉर्मेशन का आप क्या
कर सकते हो अपने जो अटैक स्ट्रेटजी है जो
आपकी हैकिंग स्ट्रेटजी है उनको क्रिएट
करने के लिए यूज कर सकते हो और एडवांस
अटैक परफॉर्म करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो
विद दी हेल्प ऑफ दीज इंफो फॉर्मेशन अब
ग्रुप्स फॉर्म्स एंड ब्लॉग्स मे आल्सो
प्रोवाइड सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट अ
टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन सच एज पब्लिक नेटवर्क
इंफॉर्मेशन सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशन एंड पर्सनल
इंफॉर्मेशन जो आपके ग्रुप्स होते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल फॉर्म्स या ब्लॉग्स जो आप
देखते हो थ्रू य या व्हाट एवर मीडियम यह
सारे के सारे क्या करते हैं किसी भी
टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बारे में सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन एक्सपोज करते हैं जाने या
अनजाने में अब जो इंटरनेट आर्काइव्स मे
आल्सो प्रोवाइड सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन दैट
हैज बीन रिमूव्ड फ्रॉम द वर्ल्ड वाइड वेब
अब इंटरनेट आर्काइव्स क्या होते हैं हम
अपकमिंग क्लासेस में पढ़ने वाले हैं इसके
थ्रू से हम कैसे इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर कर सकते
क्या होता है कि कोई भी वेबसाइट होती है
वर्ल्ड वड जैसे ही उसको अपग्रेड किया जाता
है या अपडेट किया जाता है तो क्या करता है
कई बार व अपने जो प्रीवियस कुछ दो साल
पहले या तीन साल पहले उस पर जो भी वेब
पेजे थे या जो भी सर्विस थी उनको क्या
करते वो रिमूव कर देते हैं तो उस टाइम पर
क्या है कि जो आपका इंटरनेट आरके है उस
इंफॉर्मेशन को भी कैप्चर करके रखता है
उसके स्क्रीनशॉट रखता है वेबक यूआरएल के
बारे में आपने सुना होगा तो वो एक इंटरनेट
आर्काइव है
ओके अभी बात करते हैं कि अगर मुझे फुट
प्रिंटिंग करनी है सोशल मीडिया नेटवर्क
सोशल नेटवर्किंग साइट के थ्रू तो कौन-कौन
सी इंफॉर्मेशन वहां पर मुझे देखने को
मिलती है तो फुटप्रिंटिंग थ्रू सोशल
नेटवर्किंग साइट्स ड्यूरिंग इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग यू नीड टू गैदर पर्सनल इंफॉर्मेशन
अबाउट एंप्लॉई वर्किंग इन क्रिटिकल
पोजीशंस इन द टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन अभी जब
भी हम इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करते हैं तो हम
क्या करते हैं किसी भी कंपनी में जो
एंप्लॉय काम करते हैं उनकी भी पर्सनल
इंफॉर्मेशन हम गैदर करने में इंटरेस्टेड
होते हैं ओके फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे कि चीफ
इंफॉर्मेशन सिक्योरिटी ऑफिसर सीईएसओ उसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन अगर हमें मिल जाती है मोस्ट
वेलकम सिक्योरिटी आर्किटेक्ट या नेटवर्क
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है अगर य इन एंप्लॉयज की
इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग में हम सक्सेसफुल है
तो दे आर वेरी वेल वी गेन मोर इंपोर्टेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन ओके तो सोशल नेटवर्किंग साइट्स
आर ऑनलाइन सर्विसेस और प्लेटफॉर्म्स दैट
अलाउ पीपल टू कांटेक्ट एंड बिल्ड
इंटरपर्सनल रिलेशंस अब जो भी सोशल
नेटवर्किंग साइट्स होती हैं या जो भी
प्लेटफॉर्म्स होते हैं उनके थ्रू हम क्या
करते हैं इंटरपर्सनल रिलेशंस बनाते हैं हम
नहीं जानते लेकिन किसी भी एक कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशन के थ्रू ब्लाइंड हम क्या करते
हैं एक ट्रस्ट करते हैं एक दूसरे के साथ
कम्युनिकेट करते हैं पीपल यूजुअली मेंटेन
प्रोफाइल्स ऑन सो सोल नेटवर्किंग साइट्स
एंड प्रोवाइड्स बेसिक इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट
देम सेल्व डेल्ट हेल्प टू मेक एंड मेंटेन
कनेक्शन विद अदर्स ओके द प्रोफाइल जनरली
कंटेंस इंफॉर्मेशन सच एस नेम कांटेक्ट
इंफॉर्मेशन
सेलफोन नंबर ईमेल एड्रेस फ्रेंड्स
इंफॉर्मेशन इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट फैमिली
मेंबर्स देयर इंटरेस्ट देयर हॉबीज देयर
एक्टिविटीज एटस ये सारी इंफॉर्मेशन हमें
क्या है सोशल नेटवर्किंग साइट के थ्रू
मिलती
ऑन सोशल नेटवर्किंग साइट्स पीपल मे आल्सो
पोस्ट देयर पर्सनल इंफॉर्मेशन सच एस डेट
ऑफ बर्थ एजुकेशन इंफॉर्मेशन
एंप्लॉयमेंट बैकग्राउंड स्पाउस नेम्स
स्पाउस का मतलब क्या कि वाइफ सिस्टर मदर
फादर ब्रदर्स यह उनकी इंफॉर्मेशन उनके
नाम ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
ऑन पोस्ट इंफॉर्मेशन सच एज पोटेंशियल
पार्टनर्स वेब साइड्स एंड अपकमिंग न्यूज
अबाउट द कंपनी अभी क्या होता है कि जो
ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस होती हैं उनको भी क्या है
कि
काफी इंटरेस्ट रहता है क्योंकि अपने आप
उनको ग्रो करना है ग्रो करने के लिए क्या
करते हैं सम टाइम्स वो इन सोशल मीडिया
प्लेटफॉर्म पे क्या करते हैं अपने
पार्टनर्स के साथ जब व बात करते हैं कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशन
एक्सचेंज करते हैं टैग करते हैं कमेंट
करते हैं या कई बार क्या है कि कई नई
अपकमिंग जो वेबसाइट्स हैं जो सर्विसेस है
उनको हम वो क्या कर देते हैं एक एज ए
न्यूज एक शॉर्ट थंबनेल के थ्रू या एक
वॉलपेपर के थ्रू व्हाट एवर मीडियम वे क्या
करते हैं लिक कर देते हैं क्योंकि उनको
पॉपुलर होना है तो इस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन
भी किसी भी अटैकर्स के लिए हैकर्स के लिए
काफी यूजफुल साबित हो सकती है अब जो सोशल
नेटवर्किंग साइट्स है ऑफ प्रूव टू बी
वैल्युएबल इंफॉर्मेशन रिसोर्सेस एग्जांपल
ऑफ द सच साइट्स इंक्लूड लिंकन
अभी ओके नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर चलते हैं बाय
फुटप्रिंटिंग थ्रू सोशल नेटवर्किंग साइट्स
यू कैन एक्स्टेक्स्ट पर्सनल इंफॉर्मेशन
नेम पोजीशन ऑर्गेनाइजेशन नेम करंट लोकेशन
एंड एजुकेशन क्वालिफिकेशन ये सारी के सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन क्या कर सकते हो आप सोशल
नेटवर्किंग साइट की फुटप्रिंटिंग करके पता
कर सकते हो यू कैन आल्सो फाइंड प्रोफेशनल
इंफॉर्मेशन सच एज कंपनी और बिजनेस करंट
लोकेशन फोन नंबर्स ईमेल आईडी फोटोज
वीडियोस एटस ये सारी की सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
भी हम क्या कर सकते हैं फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हैं दी इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर्ड कैन बी यूजफुल
टू परफॉर्म सोशल इंजीनियरिंग एंड अदर
टाइप्स ऑफ एडवांस अटैक्स अब ये जो सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन है इसको हम क्या कर सकते हैं
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग या कुछ और टाइप्स के जो
एडवांस अटैक्स होते हैं फिशिंग अटैक्स या
मशियल ईमेल अटैचमेंट्स होती हैं वो सारी
चीजें हम क्या कर सकते हैं ट्राई कर सकते
हैं नेटवर्क के अंदर एंटर करने के लिए
ज्यादा से ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन गेटिंग करने
के लिए किसी भी सिस्टम को कंप्रोमाइज करने
के लिए अभी जो सोशल नेटवर्किंग साइट के
थ्रू इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कैसे की जाती है
तो जो मेरी ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस की एक
प्लेलिस्ट है उसमें मैंने वेरी वेल
एक्सप्लेन किया है कि अगर मेरे पास कोई एक
इमेज है तो इमेज ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
कैसे करूंगा कि एक इमेज के थ्रू मैं
क्या-क्या इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर सकता हूं
वो भी मैंने एक्सप्लेन किया है उस
प्लेलिस्ट के अंदर दूसरा लिंक दिन के थ्रू
कैसे इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर सकता हूं वो
भी मैंने एक्सप्लेन किया है
बहुत सारे फिल्टर्स बहुत सारे तरीके
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के देखने को मिलेंगे
सीखने को मिलेंगे ओके तो यू कैन डू इट
वेरी
वेल नाउ एवरीवन गट क्लियर टिल
नाउ अभी तक किसी को कोई डाउट तो नहीं है
स्टिल एनी वन हैव डाउट्स तो देन फॉलो द
स्टेप्स वट एवर आई टेल यू इन द बिफोर
स्टार्टिंग ऑफ क्लास
ओके चलो नेक्स्ट उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे
कि जब हम
सोशल जो वेब सर्विसेस है उसके एक बार
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करेंगे देन उसके बाद
हम क्या करेंगे ईमेल हार्वेस्टिंग करेंगे
अब ईमेल हार्वेस्टिंग क्या होता है और
ईमेल हार्वेस्टिंग हमें किस टाइप की
इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिलती है वह सब अभी
हम जस्ट पीपीटी के थ्रू समझते समझेंगे
उसके बाद बाद में हम क्या करेंगे अपने
प्रैक्टिकल वे तरीके से भी समझेंगे ईमेल्स
आर मैसेजिंग सोर्स दैट आर वेरी इंपोर्टेंट
फॉर परफॉर्मिंग इंफॉर्मेशन
एक्सचेंज एंड ईमेल आईडी इज कंसीडर्ड बाय
मोस्ट पीपल एज द पर्सनल आइडेंट
ऑफ द एंप्लॉई और ऑर्गेनाइजेशन देखो अभी
मुझे अगर किसी भी एक व्यक्ति से बात करने
के लिए या मतलब की कहीं पर भी वन स्टेट टू
अनदर स्टेट या मुझे अपने वन कंट्री टू
अनदर कंट्री या वन ऑर्गेनाइजेशन टू अनदर
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन और भी एक ट्रस्ट तरीके से या
मुझे तो उसका एक ही तरीका है कि ईमेल्स
ईमेल्स को हम क्या कर सकते हैं ट्रस्ट
मैसेजिंग सोर्स मानते हैं और जिसके अंदर
क्या होती है आपकी ईमेल आईडी हम जो ईमेल
आईडी है उसको हम किसी भी एंप्लॉई की या
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की क्या होते हैं पर्सनल
आइडेंटिफिकेशन मांगते हैं क्योंकि जब भी
हम क्या करते हैं किसी भी वेबसाइट प लॉगइन
करते हैं साइन अप करते हैं तो वहां सबसे
पहले एक कॉलम पक्का मिलता है आपको ईमेल
आईडी क्योंकि ईमेल आईडी एक ट्रस्ट
मैसेजिंग सोर्स है इसलिए आप क्या है ईमेल
आईडी वेरी बहुत ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट रोल
प्ले करता है कि भी इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
में सो कलेक्शन ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट ईमेल
आईडी ऑफ क्रिटिकल पर्सनल इज वन ऑफ द की
टास्क ऑफ एथिकल हैकर्स ओबवियसली अगर यह
ईमेल आईडी अगर इतनी इंपोर्टेंट है तो किसी
भी क्रिटिकल पर्सन चाहे सीओओ की ईमेल मिल
जाए या फाउंडर की ईमेल मिल जाए या सीटीओ
की ईमेल मिल जाए सीसो की ईमेल मिल जाए या
मैनेजर की ई मेेल या जो मतलब डायरेक्टली
अफेक्ट कर सकता है किसी भी सिस्टम को अगर
उनकी ईमेल आईडी अगर मैं
सक्सेसफुली गेट इन पता करने में सक्सेस हो
जाऊं या पता कर लूं
तो काफी यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन साबित हो सकती
है और ये एक की टास्क होता है किसी भी
एथिकल हैकर के लिए तो व्हाई दिस सिंपल
इंफॉर्मेशन सो इंपोर्टेंट क्यों बिकॉज
व्हेन वी फाइंड ईमेल्स पर्टिनेंट टू ए
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट देन द अटैकर कुड यूज दैट
ईमेल टू सेंड ए मिलिशिया और फेसिंग
अटैचमेंट्स जब अगर मुझे एक बार किसी भी
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट की ईमेल आईडी मिल जाएगी
तो मैं क्या करूंगा उसके ऊपर मिशिस या
फेसिंग अटैचमेंट्स सेंड करूंगा भेजूंगा इन
दिस सेक्शन वी विल गैदर द लिस्ट ऑफ ईमेल
आईडी रिलेटेड टू द टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
यूजिंग द हार्वेस्टर टूल अभी यहां पर ईमेल
हार्वेस्टिंग परफॉर्म करने के लिए हम एक
टूल का यूज़ करेंगे जिसका नाम है द
हार्वेस्टर टूल इन अपकमिंग सेशन दिस टूल
गैदर्स ईमेल्स सब डोमस होस्ट एंप्लॉई
नेम्स ओपन पोर्ट्स बैनर्स फ्रॉम डिफरेंट
पब्लिक सोर्सेस सच एज सर्च इंजंस पीजीपी
की सर्वर्स एंड द सडन कंप्यूटर डेटाबेस एज
वेल एज
टू हेल्प इन द अर्ली स्टेजेस ऑफ़ द
सिक्योरिटी असेसमेंट टू अंडरस्टैंड द
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन फुटप्रिंट ऑन द इंटरनेट ओके
इट ये आप सेल्फ एक्सप्लेनेटरी है कुछ भी
अ फास्ट या कुछ भी ऐसा हार्ड पार्ट नहीं
है तो जब आपके पास ईमेल हार्वेस्टिंग के
थ्रू किसी भी कंपनी की किसी भी टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की या किसी भी एंप्लॉई की
ईमेल होगी तो उसके बाद आप क्या करोगे उसके
बाद बताइए आप क्या करोगे आपके पास अगर
ईमेल होगी तो अ व्हाट यू विल डू
बताइए बताइए बताइए बताइए
ओके ये तो कर सकते हैं उसके बाद हम क्या
करेंगे ओबवियसली अगर मुझे फर्द इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग करेंगे करनी है अगर य उस ईमेल के
बेस प मैं क्या करूंगा ईमेल फुटप्रिंटिंग
करूंगा अभी आप बोलो सर ईमेल हार्वेस्टिंग
और फुटप्रिंटिंग नाम अलग-अलग है ज्यादा
डिफरेंस नहीं है बस समझने को उस ईमेल
फुटप्रिंटिंग में क्या होता है देखो एज ए
प्रोफेशनल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर यू नीड यू
नीड टू बी एबल टू ट्रैक ईमेल्स ऑफ
इंडिविजुअल्स एंप्लॉय फ्रॉम ए टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन फॉर गैदरिंग क्रिटिकल
इंफॉर्मेशन दैट कैन हेल्प इन बिल्डिंग एन
इफेक्टिव हैकिंग स्ट्रेटजी ओके आप फेसिंग
तो कर ही सकते हैं लेकिन उसके अलावा भी उस
ईमेल के बेस पर भी आप क्या कर सकते हो
इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग और भी ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
कर सकते हो उस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बारे में कैसे जो ईमेल
फुटप्रिंटिंग और ट्रैकिंग जिसको हम बोलते
हैं इज ए मेथड टू मॉनिटर और स्पाई ऑन ईमेल
डिलीवर्ड टू द इंटेंडेड
रेसिपिटिन होती है जिसको हम या ईमेल
ट्रैकिंग बोल सकते हैं वो एक तरीका है या
किसी भी तरीका या किसी भी ईमेल को मॉनिटर
हो स्पाई करने का जो रिसिपिएंट है जो
रिसीवर है उसको डिलीवर की गई है तो दिस
काइंड ऑफ ट्रैकिंग इज पॉसिबल थ्रो डिजिटली
टाइम स्टेप्ड रिकॉर्ड्स दैट रिवील्स द
टाइम एंड डेट व्हेन द टारगेट रिसीव एंड
ओपन ए स्पेसिफिक ईमेल ओके एंड ईमेल
फुटप्रिंटिंग रिवील्स इंफॉर्मेशन सच एज
व्हाट टाइप ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन
रेसिपिटिन आईपी एड्रेस ये इंफॉर्मेशन क्या
कर सकता है एक्सपोज कर सकता है बता सकता
है द जीपीएस कोऑर्डिनेट्स एंड द मैप
लोकेशन ऑफ द रेसिपिटिन मेे आपको देखने को
मिल सकती है व्हेन एन ईमेल मैसेज वाज
रिसीवड एंड रीड ये इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने
को मिलेगी टाइप ऑफ सर्वर यूज्ड बाय द रे
रिसीवर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एंड ब्राउजर
इंफॉर्मेशन इफ ए डिस्ट्रक्टिव ईमेल वाज
सेंट द टाइम स्पेंड रीडिंग द ईमेल वेदर और
नॉट द रिसिपिएंट विजिटेक सेंड टू द ईमेल
पीडीएफ एंड अदर टाइप्स ऑफ अटैचमेंट्स इफ
मैसेज वर सेट टू एक्सपायर आफ्टर स्पेसिफिक
टाइम यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आप क्या कर सकते
हो फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो ईमेल फुट
प्रिंटिंग के थ्रू ईमेल ट्रैकिंग के थ्रू
तो एक टूल है ईमेल ट्रैकर प्रो तो हम उस
परे ट्राई करेंगे फ्री वर्जन के थ्रू यह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करेंगे ओके वी गट वी आर लकी इफ य गट
सक्सेसफुल या हमें इंफॉर्मेशन मिली तो अदर
वाइज क्या कि वी कैन ट्राई इट ओनली ओके तो
नेक्स्ट अभी बात करते हैं हम प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेट चलो तो अभी जो हमारा टास्क
रहेगा इन अपकमिंग क्लासेस में सबसे पहले
जो मैं आपको बता देता हूं पहले ही अपकमिंग
क्लासेस में क्या होने वाला है जो फुट
प्रिंटिंग वेब सर्विसेस के थ्रू और यह जो
ईमेल फुटप्रिंटिंग वाला जो पार्ट है ईमेल
फुटप्रिंटिंग और ईमेल हार्वेस्टिंग वाला
इसके ऊपर जितने भी प्रैक्टिकल्स है जितने
भी टूल्स है जो मेरे पास अवेलेबल है वो
सारे टूल्स मैं आपको परफॉर्म करके
दिखाऊंगा उसके बाद ही हम नेक्स्ट स्टेप पे
बढ़ेंगे जो कि हमारा क्या हो सकता है
डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग हो सकता है अदर वाइज
क्या है कि सबसे पहले हम अपने
प्रैक्टिकल्स में वह सारे टूल्स ट्राई
करेंगे मैं वह सारे टूल्स परफॉर्म करके
दिखाऊंगा ज्यादा से ज्यादा टूल आपको
परफॉर्म करके दिखाऊंगा प्रैक्टिकल्स
प्रैक्टिकली कि किस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको देखने को मिलती है ड्यूरिंग
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग तो सबसे पहले जो टूल्स
हम परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं उसका नाम है नेट
क्राफ्ट ओके नेट क्राफ्ट इट प्रोवाइड्स ए
लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट एन वेबसाइट जैसे
कि बैकग्राउंड इंफॉर्मेशन लाइक साइट टाइटल
साइट रैंक डेट फर्स्ट सीन दिस स्पेलिंग
मिस्टेक है इट्स माय मिस्टेक प्राइमरी
लैंग्वेज ऑन द वेबसाइट एक्सट्रा नेटवर्क
इंफॉर्मेशन लाइक डोमेन इंफॉर्मेशन आईपी
एड्रेस इंफॉर्मेशन नेम सर्वर्स इंफॉर्मेशन
टॉप लेवल डोमेन इंफॉर्मेशन एटस ऑल टाइप्स
ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन
एसएसएल टी एलएस सर्टिफिकेट इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको देखने को मिलेगी सर्टिफाइड
ट्रांसपेरेंसी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को
मिलेगी इंफॉर्मेशन रिगार्डिंग दिस साइट इज
वेलेबल टूू एनी एसएसएल टी एलएस रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन होस्टिंग हिस्ट्री वेब ट्रैकर
इंफॉर्मेशन साइट टेक्नोलॉजी इंफॉर्मेशन तो
सबसे पहले हम जो प्रैक्टिकल करने वाले हैं
मैं आपको एक बार परफॉर्म करके दिखाऊंगा कि
नेट क्राफ्ट जो टूल्स है आपका जो ग्राफिकल
यूजर बेस j आई टूल्स है वो किस तरह की
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको किसी भी डोमस के ऊपर
प्रोवाइड करता है इस टाइप की कोई भी
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करता है उसको हम क्या
करते हैं ब प्रैक्टिकली देखते हैं देन
नेक्स्ट जो इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग स्टेप्स है
हमारा प्रैक्टिकली वो हम बात करेंगे सडन
सभी ने पता है सबको पता है सडन क्या है
सडन ये वाला दिस वन सडन इसके ऊपर हम
डिटेल्स एक्सप्लेन करेंगे आज डिटेल्स में
जितना मतलब मैं मैक्सिमम ट्राई करूंगा
उसके ऊपर आपको आर्टिकल्स भी प्रोवाइड कर
दूंगा जिससे आप प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो और
मैं आपको दिखा दूं क्योंकि एक पेड टूल है
और मे भी आपके पास इसका एक्सेस नहीं हो
लेकिन आप यहां पर देख के सीख सकते हो कि
सडन का कैसे यूज किया जाता है इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग में
ओके चलो अभी हम चलते हैं अपनी मशीन के ऊपर
गो टू
आवर काली लिनेक्स
ओके डोंट वरी आई विल
जूम
चलो सबको दिखाई दे रहा है
ओके
चलो सबसे पहले जो हम सर्च कर रहे हैं वह
हमारा नेट
क्राफ्ट ये रहा नेट
क्राफ्ट दिस वन ncr.com
देन स्क्रोल डाउन स्क्रोल डाउन ओके
डिक्लाइन नो इशू स्क्रोल डाउन स्क्रोल
डाउन स्क्रोल डाउन आपको जाना है कहां
पर यह रहा एनालाइज वाले पार्ट पर हम एक
बार क्या करते हैं
इसको ओके एक्सेप्ट कोके नाउ दिस इज द पेज
यहां पर हम क्या करेंगे फॉर एग्जांपल मुझे
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करनी है किसके
रिगार्डिंग डेफ जो मेरी वेबसाइट है उससे
रिलेटेड जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन है अगर मुझे वो
कैप्चर करनी है तो मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं
ओके तो
डडड कॉ ओके
नाउ लुक अप तो देखि व्ट टाइप ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन इ प्रोवाइड देखिए कि एटीटीपी
https.com देखिए
बैकग्राउंड म ओके इसको हम एटीपीएस भी कर
सकते हैं नो इशू तो यहां पर देखिए आपको
बैकग्राउंड में साइट टाइटल 30 मड परमा ली
ओके सबसे पहली बार इसको कब यूज किया गया
था जुलाई 23 में एंड साइट की रैंकिंग क्या
है अभी देख सकते हो आप नॉट प्रेजेंट
प्राइमरी लैंग्वेज क्या इंग्लिश है और
डिस्क्रिप्शन यहां पर प्रेजेंट नहीं है
रिलेटेड टू डेफ अकेडमी एंड नेटवर्क
इंफॉर्मेशन क्या साइट है
http.com डोमेन है de.com एंड नेट ब्लॉक
नर मतलब क्लाउड फ्लेयर होस्टिंग सर्विस
यूज की गई है नेम सर्वर इंफॉर्मेशन क्या
है दिस इज द नेम सर्वर इफ फॉर्मेशन है
होस्टिंग कंपनी क्या है क्लाउड फेयर है
डोमेन रजिस्ट्रार अननोन यह मेंशन नहीं
किया गया होस्टिंग कंट्री कौन सी है यूएस
है आईपीवी एड्रेस क्या है इसका
1726 7189 ए0 देन उसके बाद डीएनएस एडमिन
की इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है एंड आईपी
ऑटोनोमस सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशन आईपीवी सिक्स
एड्रेस इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है टॉप लेवल
डोमेन इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है उसके बाद
डीएनएस सिक्योरिटी एक्सटेंशन इनेबल है अ
देन उसके बाद आईपी डेलिगेशन आईपी एड्रेस
रिलेशन आपको इंफ देखने को मिल सकती है ओके
दीज आर द आईपी एड्रेसस इंफॉर्मेशन आईपीवी
फॉर एड्रेस इंफॉर्मेशन एंड आईपीवी सि
एड्रेस इंफॉर्मेशन एसएसएल टीएस से रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिल रही है कि
दिस इज नॉट ए एचटीटीपीएस साइट व लुक ओके
एचटीटीपीएस साइट रिपोर्ट ओके मैं एक काम
करता हूं इसको एक बार
एचटीटीपीएस ओके फिर से हम क्या करते
हैं इनको थोड़ा सा कंफ्यूज आ रहा है नो
इशू
चलो चलो इंफॉर्मेशन आई है नाउ उसके बाद ये
रहा देखो एसएसएल टी एलएस इंफॉर्मेशन अबकी
बार यहां पर आपको देखने को मिल रही है
जैसे कि डोमेन वैलिडेशन यस परफेक्ट फॉर
सिक्योरिटी यस एंड ऑर्गेनाइजेशन स्टेट नॉट
प्रेजेंट अल्टरनेटिव नेम्स de.com देन इर
यूनिट देन देर लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन आर
अवेलेबल हियर कौन सा टी एलएस वर्जन यूज कर
रहे हैं 1.3 यूज किया जा रहा है पीके लेंथ
256 यूज कि वेरी सिक्योर्ड एंड सर्टिफिकेट
चेक ओके देन साट 56 एल्गोरिथम का यूज किया
जा रहा है
एंड दीज आर द साइफर्स टीस मतलब वे
सिक्योर्ड एसएसएल टीएल एस जो यूज किया गया
है डोंट ब्रेकेबल
देन सर्टिफाइड ट्रांसपेरेंसी इंफॉर्मेशन
देखिए यह रहा सर्टिफिकेट अननोन टाइम स्टेप
अननोन देन एसएसएल पोर्टल दिस साइड डज नॉट
सपोर्ट एस वर्जन 3 प्रोटोकॉल ओके हार्ड
ब्लीड मस साइड ड नॉट ऑफर द हार्ड ब्लीड लस
एक्सटेंशन प्र टू हार्ड बड मतलब यहां पर
क्या कि एसएसएल और टेलर से रिलेटेड अटैक्स
पॉसिबल नहीं है अकॉर्डिंग टू दिस
इंफॉर्मेशन जो आपके सामने शो किया गया है
वेब ट्रैकर इंफॉर्मेशन आपको आपके सामने शो
की गई वेब ट्रैकर आ थर्ड पार्टी रिसोर्सेस
वेब सो ये इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है नाउ
वेबसाइट टेक्नोलॉजी कौन सी यूज किया जाए
एचटीटीपी एटर क्लाउड फेयर देन करंट ली
नेटवर्क क्लाउड फ्लेयर वेब ब्राउजिंग
टारगेटिंग कंटेंट सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी
डिटेक्ट एंड मल्टी स्टेयर अटैक इन द
ब्राउजर ओके डिस्क्रिप्शन पॉपुलर साइट्स
यूजिंग दिस टेक्नोलॉजी नाउ देर लॉट ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन आर अवेलेबल फॉर दिस वेबसाइट तो
यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन क्या करता है आपका जो
नेट क्राफ्ट है बेसिकली क्या करता है नेट
क्राफ्ट क्या करता है आपकी जो वज
इंफॉर्मेशन है रिलेटेड टू योर वेबसाइट जो
आप वज के थ्रू गेट करते हो जो आपने वज
किया था किसी भी वेबसाइट से रिलेटेड तो
वही सेम इंफॉर्मेशन आपका नेट क्राफ्ट टूल
प्रोवाइड करता है ओके गेट
क्लियर डोंट
वरी शुभम व्हाट इज एसएसएल एंड टीएल एस
अपकमिंग क्लास में मैं आपको डिटेल्स में
बता दूंगा कि एसएसएल और टीएल एस होते क्या
है ओके यह जब मैं आपको क्रिप्टोग्राफी
बताऊंगा तो समझाऊ तो उसमें आपको मैं
डिजिटल सर्टिफिकेट के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड करूंगा तो वहां पर आपको ए एसस और
टीएल से रिलेटेड काफी डीप में नॉलेज दूंगा
आपको ओके
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आप लोग के लिए यूजफुल
नहीं है बेसिकली आपके लिए
ओके तो अभी हम नेक्स्ट सोडा के बारे में
पढ़ते
हैं आज बहुत ही कम स्टूडेंट्स हैं जो
क्लास में आए हैं आई एम वेरी डिसइंटेरड
[संगीत]
रहा तो फिर मैं
क्लास वीक में एक ही डिलीवर करूंगा और आई
विल एंजॉय माय टाइम आई विल नॉट वेस्ट माय
टाइम ओके अगर आप लोग ऐसा करोगे तो तो
प्लीज बेयर विद मी आप लोग मेरा साथ दीजिए
और ट्राई कीजिए कि
मैक्सिमम क्लास लाइव क्लास को अटेंड करो
क्योंकि उससे बेनिफिट आपको है एक बार आप
क्लास मिस कर दोगे तो हर एक क्लास
डिपेंडेंट है हर एक क्लास एक दूसरे के ऊपर
डिपेंड रहेगी ऐसा नहीं कि आज की क्लास पढ़
ली तो फर्स्ट क्लास और सेकंड ट नहीं नहीं
भी पढ़ूंगा काम चल जाएगा मानता हूं कि आप
लोगों को कि थोड़ी ये इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
स्टेप्स पता होगा ठीक है बट इसके बाद जो
मैं स्टार्ट करूंगा इंफॉर्मेशन एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग बहुत सारी ऐसी चीजें
होंगी जो मैं आपको कुछ एक सिनेरियो के
थ्रू बताऊंगा मुझे पता आपको पता होगा कि
ऐसा नहीं कि डेफिनेटली आपको एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग नहीं करनी आती या
पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग नहीं आती लेकिन
मैं जिस तरीके से आपको बता रहा हूं एक
अप्रोच है पैसिव और एक्टिव पैसिव में क्या
डिफरेंस और में क्या डिफरेंस है ओके ओके
जो जो आपके बेसिक्स है वो सारी मैं इस
तरीके एक्सप्लेन करूंगा कल को आप इंटरव्यू
में बैठोगे इंटरव्यू में किसी ने आपसे
पूछा तो आप डायरेक्टली उनके जो क्वेश्चंस
के आंसर आप प्रोवाइड कर पाओगे ये इस तरीके
से अप्रोच में आपको पढ़ा रहा हूं मुझे पता
है कि आप मैं आपको डायरेक्टली टूल्स बता
दूंगा सडन को ऐसे यूज करना है माल्ट को
ऐसे यूज करना है और रिकन एनजी को ऐसे यूज
करना है एमास को सब फाइंडर सबलिस्ट देर
लॉट ऑफ टूल्स आर अवेलेबल न्यूक्लि आई तो
मैं आपको सीध टूल्स की लिस्ट प्रोवाइड कर
देता हूं एक बार रन करके दिखा देता हूं
आपको यह ना बताऊ कि एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग क्या होती है और पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग क्या होती है क्या डिफरेंस है
डिफरेंस है और कब करनी चाहिए कब नहीं करनी
चाहिए और कैसे करते हैं उसके बाद हम
नेक्स्ट फेज में कैसे करेंगे यह पढ़ने कीत
ये सारी चीज आपको पता ही नहीं होगा तो बस
ठीक है ब्लाइंड करते रहो कोई इशू नहीं है
हर कोई ऐसे कर लेगा और हर कोई ऐसे सीखता
भी है तो मुझे भी किसी ने ऐसे सिखाया था
बट मैं खुद से एक्सप्लेन चाहिए सारी चीजें
तो वही चीज मैं आपको सा चाहता हूं कि आप
लोग वो गलतियां ना करें अभी मैं इतना
प्रेसा इजली आपको बता रहा हूं कि आपके
दिमाग में कोई भी डाउट नहीं रहेगा कि अभी
तक जो मैं टूल्स यूज किए जो भी किया कि
मैं सोचिए कि मैंने अभी तक ये टूल यूज
किया क्या मैं एक्टिवली इंगेज हुआ fix.com
के साथ नहीं हुआ और सडन को यूज कर मतलब
अभी तक जितने भी टूल्स य कर एक्टिवली मैं
किसी के साथ भी अभी इंगेज नहीं कर रहा मैं
सिर्फ ओनली वेबसाइट को पता भी नहीं उससे
रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन मैं गेटिंग कर रहा हूं
कि उससे रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन मैं पता कर
रहा हूं क्योंकि जो ऑलरेडी पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन स उसी को मैं फाइंड
आउट कर रहा हूं अभी से मैंने f.com जो
वेबसाइट है उसके के साथ मैंने एक्टिवली
इंगेजमेंट किया ही नहीं है उसके साथ मैं
एक्टिव हुआ ही नहीं हूं कि एक्टिवली उसम
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की नहीं है क्योंकि
अभी तक मैंने सिर्फ ओनली उसकी जो पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन है मैं उसी पे आप फोकस
कर रहा हूं वही मैक्सिमम इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट करने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं कि ये तरीके हैं कि आप
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो देर आ लॉट
ऑफ टूल्स और मैं आपको एक चीज बता द हूं कि
ये सारे टूल्स हैं या जो भी है इन लिंक को
सेव करके रखोगे इन फ्यूचर में कभी भी कोई
भी एग्जाम दोगे तो जितने भी जो एथिकल है
हैकिंग के जो एग्जाम्स होते हैं या
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के एग्जाम्स सारे ओपन
बुक एग्जाम्स होते हैं आप चीटिंग कर सकते
हो कोई इशू नहीं लेकिन आपके पास अगर एक
रोड मैप और आपके पास लिस्ट ऑफ टूल्स किस
टूल को कब यूज करना है और किस टूल को यूज
करने की जरूरत ही नहीं है तो जब आपको ये
सब पता ही नहीं होगा तो आप एग्जाम क्रैक
ही नहीं कर पाओगे क्योंकि आपका टोटली टाइम
वेस्ट हो जाएगा हर टूल को परफॉर्म करके
क्योंकि हर एक टूल को परफॉर्म करने की
जरूरत नहीं होती है आपको जब एक बार
परफॉर्म करने के बाद आपको पता कि किस टूल
की क्या एक्यूरेसी है लास्ट कब अपडेट हुआ
था और कितना उसको फ्रिक्वेंटली इंडस्ट्री
लेवल पर यूज य किया जाता है तो सारी चीज
इफॉर्म आपके पास तो जो आपको 500 टूल में
से अगर आपको 50 टूल्स यूज करने तो 50
टूल्स आर बेटर रदर देन 450 टूल्स जो बचे
हुए हैं तो बस 50 टूल ही यूज कीजिए 500
टूल यूज करने की जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि
सभी का मैकेनिज्म
वर्किंग वर्किंग मैकेनिज्म या जो जिस तरह
काम करते हैं सब सेम है बेसिक फंडामेंटल
सबके सेम है इंफॉर्मेशन थोड़ा से कम
ज्यादा होती है बट क्या है कि सोचिए कि
लगभग वही इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है उसके बाद
मैनुअल अप्रोच कीजिए चलो
चलो अभी हम बात करते हैं सोडा के बारे में
एंड अभी मैं
इसको नेक्स्ट टूल है
सडन ना अभी एक सोडा टूल्स है एक क्या होता
सोडा एक सर्च पहली बात तो ओके तो हम इसके
थ्रू फुट प्रिंटिंग कैसे करेंगे और व्हाट
टाइप इंफॉर्मेशन इट विल प्रोवाइड मतलब
थोड़ा सा सडन के बारे में इंट्रोडक्शन
लेते हैं देन हम प्रैक्टिकली देखेंगे कि
सडन क्या है सडन इज ए सर्च इंजन ऑन व्हिच
वी कैन सी ऑल द डिवाइसेज वच आर कनेक्टेड
ऑन द इंटरनेट जितने भी डिवाइस आपके
इंटरनेट से कनेक्टेड है उन सबकी
इंफॉर्मेशन हम क्या कर सकते हैं सडन सर्च
इंधन के थ्रू क्रॉल कर सकते हैं देख सकते
हैं डिवाइस का मतलब क्या है प्रिंटर्स
रेफ्रिजरेटर्स कंप्यूटर राउटर्स मॉडम
सर्वर्स या जो भी चीज इंटरनेट से कनेक्ट
हो सकती है या जो चीज इंटरनेट का यूज करती
है वह सारे डिवाइस के अंदर आते हैं सडन की
भाषा में इट इज डिफरेंट फ्रॉम सर्च इंजन
लाइक
अभी जो गल और बिन है वह क्या करते हैं
जितने भी वेबसाइट्स है उनको क्रॉल करते
हैं लेकिन जो सडन है वह क्या करता है
जितने भी
डिवाइसेसपोर्ट
[संगीत]
उनको क्रॉल करते हैं और उनका जो रिजल्ट्स
है उनको क्या करते अपने डेटाबेस में स्टोर
करते हैं सोडा गैदर इंफॉर्मेशन बाय
इंटरेक्ट विद द वेब सर्विसेस एंड दिस
इंफॉर्मेशन इज स्टोर्ड इन एन ऑब्जेक्ट
कॉल्ड द बैनर अभी जो डान है वह क्या करता
है वेब सर्विसेस के थ्रू इंटरेक्ट करता है
उसके बाद इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करता है
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करने के बाद वो किसी एक
ऑब्जेक्ट में स्टोर करता है जिसको हम बैनर
बोलते हैं सो व्हेन यू सर्च एनीथिंग
यूजिंग ए सडन डोर अब जब सडन के सर्च
क्यूरी को यूज करके जब इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं तो क्या करता
है सडन टेक्स द इंफॉर्मेशन फ्रॉम द बैनर
ऑफ दैट सर्विस एंड डिस्प्ले इट टू यू इन
सिंपल वर्ड्स बैनर इज ए मेटा डाटा बेसिकली
क्या उसका जो भी मेटा डाटा है जो भी
इंफॉर्मेशन है जिस टाइम प उसने उसको क्रॉल
किया क्रॉल करते वक्त जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन
उसके हाथ लगी उस सारी इंफॉर्मेशन क्या
करता है अपने डेटाबेस में स्टोर करता है
और जैसे ही आप सर्च सक्यूरी के थ्रू उसको
फाइंड आउट करते हो वो इंफॉर्मेशन अग उसके
पास अवेलेबल है वो उसको आपके सामने क्या
करता है शो कर देता है आउटपुट में सो एज ए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर वी कैन यूज ए स्पेसिफिक
सडन क्यूरी फिल्टर टू गेट द इंफॉर्मेशन
अबाउट दोज पर्टिकुलर डिवाइसेज च हैव बीन
इंडेक्स बाय सडन ओके अभी हम एज ए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर हम क्या कर सकते हैं इन
सोडा क्यूरीज या फिल्टर का यूज करके वह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करते हैं एक किसी भी पर्टिकुलर या टारगेट
डिवाइस के बारे में जो सूडान के द्वारा
इंडेक्स की गई है अगर व सूडान के डेटाबेस
में अवेलेबल नहीं है तो वी कैन नॉट फाइंड
आउट बेसिकली जो इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है वही
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं
ओके नेक्स्ट इस से आपको इंफॉर्मेशन देखने
को मिलती है दज आर द स्क्रीनशॉट फ्रॉम एक
मीडियम आर्टिकल्स है उससे मैंने इसको
स्क्रीनशॉट को उठाया था एंड थैंक यू उसने
अच्छा आर्टिकल लिखा है उस आर्टिकल को मैं
आपके सामने शेयर करूंगा और नेक्स्ट एक और
इस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को
मिलती है अभी हम इसको प्रैक्टिकली करते
हैं तो प्रैक्टिकली करने से पहले मैं आपको
एक चीज बता देता हूं एक आर्टिकल्स है
मीडियम पे काफी अच्छा आर्टिकल्स है मैं
आपको बता देता हूं यह आर्टिकल है सोडा
डॉग्स के बारे में द गोड साई जरी शहा तो
थैंक यू ब्रो आपने इसको काफी अच्छे से वेल
एक्सप्लेंड एक आर्टिकल लिखा है तो वेरी
वेल डन तो आपको अभी प्रमोट भी हो जाए होगे
तो सडन डॉग्स है आप इसको अच्छे से पढ़िए
यह आप आसानी से सर्च कर सकते हो जब सडन
डॉग ये सर्च मारोगे तो आपको सेम मीडियम पे
आर्टिकल देखने को मिलेगा तो आप क्या कर
सकते हो इसको एज ए नोट्स रेफर कर सकते हो
काफी डिटेल्स में काफी अच्छे से इसने
एक्सप्लेन किया है वो सारी चीजें मैं
एक्सप्लेन नहीं कर सकता लेकिन क्या है कि
मैं टाइम वेस्ट नहीं कर लेकिन जितनी चीजें
मैक्सिमम ट्राई करूंगा आपको वो एक्सप्लेन
करने की लेकिन आप इस आर्टिकल को रेफरेंस
ले सकते हो तो आपको सिंपली क्या है सडन के
बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन दी हुई है देन उसके
बाद मैं आपको बता देता हूं आपको क्या करना
है सडन क्या है दो टाइप्स दो वर्जन में
आपको देखने को मिलेगा तो वेब बेस्ड और सील
आई हम दोनों पे काम करेंगे बेसिकली मेन
फोकस करूंगा मैं सील आई पे क्योंकि सडन एक
पेड वर्जन है और उसमें क्या है कि वन टाइम
यूज के बहुत ज्यादा पैसे लगते हैं मे बी
$49 लगते हैं और
बेसिक उसका पैकेज है 69 का मंथली है तो आई
थिंक नोबडी कैन अफोर्ड तो इसलिए क्या है
कि आप सिर्फ सीखिए सडन कैसे काम करता है
व्ट टाइप इंफॉर्मेशन जब कभी आप इंडस्ट्री
में जाते हो तो आपके पास नॉलेज होगी सडन
को कैसे यूज करना है तो बेसिकली आपको क्या
करना है जब भी अगर आपको सडन को यूज करना
तो सिंपली आपको क्या सबसे पहले रजिस्टर
करना है अगर आप पेड वर्जन यूज करना चाहते
हो तो मेरी तरफ से कंपलसरी नहीं है आपको
पेड वर्जन यूज करने की लेकिन मैं आपको
सिर्फ ट्रेनिंग दे रहा हूं तो आपको सिंपली
रजिस्टर करना है रजिस्टर करने के बाद जो
भी पैकेज आप कंफर्टेबल वन टाइम यूज करना
है या
आपको क्या बोलते हैं कि मंथली यूज करना है
व्हाट एवर यू चूज आपको उसके बाद क्या करना
है रजिस्टर करने के बाद लॉग इन करना है
लॉग इन करने के बाद आपको इस तरह का
डैशबोर्ड देखने को मिलेगा और इस डैशबोर्ड
देखने के बाद आप क्या कर सकते हो देन सील
आई वर्जन मैं आपको इंस्टॉल करना सिखाऊंगा
सीआई वर्जन कैसे लेकिन इसकी प्री
रिक्विजिट क्या है आपको पाइथन इंस्टॉल
होनी चाहिए आपकी सिस्टम में ओके और ऑलरेडी
नेक्स उसके अंदर पाइथन होती है तो हम वेरी
इजली सडन की जो सीएल आई है उसको कमांड
लाइड इंटरफेस को इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं तो
आपको उसके बाद क्या करना जब एक बार आप सडन
को इंस्टॉल कर लोगे सोडाल को इंस्टॉल करने
के बाद सबसे पहली चीज जो आपको करनी है
आपको जो एपीआई है टोकन है जो सडन का जो
एपीआई टोकन है उसको क्या करना है
आपको इसमें सीएल आई में ऐड करना है किसके
थ्रू यह वाली कमांड है जैसे आपको देखने को
मिलेगी सडन इनिला इज यहां पर जो हाईलाइट
वाइट कलर में आपको आपको देखने को मिले
यहां पर क्या है आपका एपीआई टोकन है आप इस
एपीआई टोकन को क्या करोगे यहां पर यूज
करोगे और जैसे ही आप एक बार इसको यूज कर
लोगे तो यहां पर ये क्या है सक्सेसफुली ऐड
हो जाएगा एपीआई टोकन इस कमांड लाइन में
फिर आप क्या कर सकते हो जो वेब बेस
इंटरफेस था आपका जो ग्राफिकल यूजर फेस
इंटरफेस था सेम आप क्या है सीआई में यूज
कर सकते हो थ्रू कमांड लाइन देन उसके बाद
क्या है एक बार आप ये इ ये आपको एपीआई
टोकन कहां पर मिलेगा जैसे ही आप एक बार
क्या कर लोगे लॉग इन कर लो लॉगिन करने के
बाद आपको सिंपली क्या करना है अकाउंट में
जाना है अकाउंट में जाने के बाद आपको खुद
की इंफॉर्मेशन जाओगे जब टोकन का व्यू
करोगे तो इस तरीके से आपको देखने को
मिलेगा आपका नाम आपका लेवल उसके बाद यहां
पर क्यूआर कोड क्यूआर कोड के ऊपर एक ये जो
रेड कलर दिख रहा है यहां पर एपीआई की
देखने को मिलेगी यहां पर हाइड की गी वेरी
वेल क्योंकि आप एपीआई की मैं भी आपको शो
नहीं करने वाला अदर वाइज यू विल यूज इट
मेरे पास ज्यादा क्रेडिट स्कोर नहीं है बस
आपके प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट को शो करने के लिए
उतना ही मेरे पास क्रेडिट बचे हुए हैं
क्यूरीज में कर सकता हूं ली हार्डली 90 टू
100 क्यूरीज आपके सामने परफॉर्म कर सकता
बट मैं इतनी करूंगा नहीं क्योंकि नेक्स्ट
क्लास में किसी को भी शो करने के लिए यूज
की जा सकती है तो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर
सकते हो सडन की की को इलाज कर सकते हो तो
मैं आपको दिखा दूंगा कि आपको कैसे इलाज
करना है अभी हम प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट करते हैं
इसका चलो गो बैक तो दिस इज योर सडन सडन
सर्च इंजन चलो यह आपका सडन सर्च डैशबोर्ड
है आपका इस तरीके से आपको शोडाउन देखने को
मिलेगा आपके स्क्रीन के ऊपर यह रहा आई होप
की सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा होगा लट ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल बट मैं सबसे पहले क्या
करूंगा कि सडन को कैसे इंस्टॉल करना मैं
आपको दिखाता हूं कमांड लाइन में सील आई
मैं आपको क्या दिखाऊंगा सील एंड इसको
मिनिमाइज करता हूं देन सील आई हम यूज
करेंगे सील आई ओके
चलो एक टर्मिनल को सेटिंग थोड़ी सी गड़बड़
हुई है इसको चेंज कर दूंगा एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ
ल मैं
इसको यह
रहा ड जूम कर रहा हूं जूम कर रहा
हूं आई थिंक दिस इ
विजिबल सबको दिखाई दे रहा है देखिए
ओके तो सबसे पहले क्या करूंगा मैं सुडो
यूजर बन जाऊंगा सुडो एयू स्विच कर लूंगा
तो मैं एक रूट यूजर बन गया रूट यूजर बनने
के बाद मुझे क्या करना है मेरी मशीन में
पाइथन इंस्टॉल होना चाहिए ओबवियसली आपकी
मशीन में जो
11.9 वर्जन में यूज कर रहा हूं देन उसके
बाद मुझे क्या करना है सिंपली एक कमांड
होती है पिप इंस्टॉल आपको कमांड का यूज
करना इंस्टॉल
सडन सो डान ओके और सिंपली हिट एंटर कर
देना है और सक्सेसफुली आप क्या कर दोगे
सडन इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा आपकी मशीन के अंदर
ओके तो इंस्टॉल हो गया तोय कुछ वार्निंग्स
है तो सिंपली आप इग्नोर कर सकते हो अभी
मुझे क्रॉस चेक करना है कि मेरा सडन
सक्सेसफुली इंस्टॉल हुआ नहीं तो मैं सडन
टाइप करूंगा जैसे सडन टाइप किया तो देखिए
ब्लू हो गया मतलब इसका मतलब मैं सडन काम
कर रहा हाइन हाइन हेल्प मेनू में चेक करता
हूं क्या तो दिस इज द हेल्प मेनू ऑफ
शोडाउन यह आपका हेल्प मेनू आपका शोडाउन का
ये
रहा इसको यूज करने का तरीका आपको शोडाउन
उसके बाद ऑप्शंस फिर कमांड उसके बाद
आर्गुमेंट आप प्रोवाइड कर सकते हो तो अभी
मैंने आपको बताया था इट आप जब भी आपको की
इ आपको क्या करना है जब आपको इनिला करना
है बेसिकली क्या करना है आपका जो सडन है
उसकी एपीआई की को इसके अंदर इंसर्ट करना
है इलाज करना उसके लिए आप यूज करोगे
सडन सडन
इट इट उसके
बाद मे में किया इट यूज करोगे देन उसके
बाद आप क्या कर सकते हो अपनी एपीआई की को
इंसर्ट कर सकते हो कैसे मैं अभी आपके
सामने दिखा देता
हूं सडन उसके बाद इट उसके बाद य पर करोगे
अपनी एपीआई
की
एपीआई की ओके एपीआई की आप इस तरह इस तरीके
से क्या कर सकते हो आप अपनी एपीआई की को
इसके अंदर सेट कर सकते हो जब आपने एक बार
एपीआई की को सेट कर लिया तो मैं चेक कर
रहा हूं एक बार इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए कि मेरे
पास कितनी क्यूरीज और कितने स्कैन बचे हुए
हैं मैं जो यूज कर सकता हूं
ओके ए इंस्टॉल शोडाउन करके देख लीजिए मे
भी अभी इन वर्जन के साथ सपोर्ट करता है
अगर मैं देखें तो एप्ट ओके
इंस्टॉल सडन काम करता है
क्या ओके ऐसे काम नहीं करेगा क्योंकि यह
क्या है पाइथन बेस्ड है तो पाइथन के अंदर
ही लाइब्रेरी के अंदर इसको ऐड किया हुआ है
तो अनेबल टू लोकेट पैकेज सडन ओके तो सडन
को आप ऐसे इंस्टॉल नहीं कर सकते तो आपको
सिंपली पिप कमांड की हेल्प से ही इंस्टॉल
करना होगा सडन को अभी जब एक बार आपने उसकी
एपीआई की
को इलाज कर दिया सेट कर दिया आपके समान
सॉरी सडन सीएल आई के साथ देन आपको क्या
करना है सडन देन उसके बाद आपको इंफो कमांड
का यूज करना है सडन इंफो हिट एंटर अभी यह
मेरे को इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करेगा कि
कितने नंबर ऑफ क्रेडिट क्योंकि आप पेड
अकाउंट यूज कर रहे हो तो पेड अकाउंट में
आपके नंबर ऑफ क्यूरीज और नंबर ऑफ स्कैनिंग
पेंडिंग रहती है कि आप इतनी अमाउंट में
इतने नंबर ऑफ स्कैनिंग और इतने नंबर ऑफ
क्या कर सकते हो आप क्यूरी कर सकते हो सडन
के अंदर एवरीवन गट क्लियर कि सबका इंस्टॉल
इंस्टॉलेशन पार्ट हो गया
सब लोग मेरे साथ कर रहे हो देखिए मेरे
पास क्यूरी क्रेडिट 100 अवेलेबल स्कैन
क्रेडिट भी मेरे पास 100 अवेलेबल मतलब
मेरे पास क्या कि मैं 100 टाइम्स ही
क्यूरी कर सकता हूं 100 टाइम्स कुछ भी
सर्च कर सकता हूं और 100 टाइम ही मैं किसी
भी आईपी एड्रेस को स्कैन कर सकता हूं एक
बार मैंने एक आईपी एड्रेस को स्कैन कर
लिया तो एक स्कैन रिजल्ट मेरा कम हो जाएगा
ओके तो प्लीज मुझे बताइए साथ के साथ सब
कितने लोग साथ के साथ कर रहे हैं
बताइए ओके कोई नहीं कर पाएगा आई थिंक
क्योंकि किसी के पास भी की नहीं होगी
एपीआई की और फ्री वर्जन य पर अवेलेबल नहीं
है ओके उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है तो
सबसे पहले मुझे चेक करना है कि मैं सडन का
वर्जन कौन सा है करंट वर्जन कौन सा तो
उसके लिए होता है
सडन हान आईन वर्जन हान वर्जन इसमें नली
सीधा
वर्जन तो यह मेरे को शो कर रहा है 1.31.0
जो प्रेजेंटली मैं अपना सडन वर्जन यूज कर
रहा हूं ओके उसके बाद एक बार मैं सडन की
हेल्प ओपन करता हूं सडन हाइन हाइन
हेल्प ओके हाइन हान हेल्प किया मैंने तो
आपको सबके आपके सबसे सामने आपको देखने को
मिल रहा है काउंट तो एक ये आपका क्या है
सबसे पहले एक एक ये फिल्टर है काउंट
फिल्टर को मैं यूज करने वाला हूं काउंट जो
ऑप्शन है ये क्या काम करता है रिटर्न्स द
नंबर ऑफ रिजल्ट फॉर ए सर्च कोई भी जब मैं
पर्टिकुलर सर्च करता हूं फॉर एग्जांपल मैं
सडन के अंदर कुछ भी सर्च करना चाहता हूं
कोई वलन बिलिटी सर्च करना चाहता हूं या
किसी आईपी एड्रेस से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन
सर्च करना चाहता हूं या कोई डोमेन से
रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन सर्च करना चाहता हूं
या किसी सर्वर से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन सर्च
करना चाहता हूं या कोई भी सर्विस से
रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन सर्च करना चाहता हूं
तो उसको हम बोल सकते हैं सर्च क्यूरी
तो उसके कितने नंबर ऑफ रिजल्ट सर्च किए
हैं उसको क्या करता काउंट करके आपकी
स्क्रीन के सामने रिटर्न कर देता कैसे फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं बात करता हूं सोडा सीओ यू
एनटी काउंट और मैं यूज कर रहा हूं अभी फॉर
एग्जांपल
मैं ओपन ऐसे सर्च करता हूं और हिट एंटर
देखिए देखिए अभी अगर मैं सोडा सर्च इंधन
के अंदर अगर ओपन एसएसएस सर्च करता हूं तो
5383 रिजल्ट मेरे को शो करेगा मेरी
स्क्रीन के ऊपर ओके तो यह आपको काउंट करके
बता रहा है कि इतने नंबर ऑफ रिजल्ट इतने
रिजल्ट मैं आपको क्या करूंगा शो करूंगा
रिलेटेड टू दिस सर्च क्यूरी जो ओपन एसस
सर्च क्यूरी है इससे रिलेटेड जो भी मेरा
रिजल्ट है उन उसकी काउंटिंग क्या है
5389 ओके
ओके नाउ उसके बाद मैं आपको दिखाता हूं एक
सबसे यूजफुल एक मोस्ट पावरफुल जो फीचर्स
होता है सडन का उसके बारे में डिस्कस करते
हैं कौन सा है वो आपको बताता हूं डाउनलोड
यह रहा एक फिल्टर जो डाउनलोड फिल्टर है यह
क्या करता है डाउनलोड सर्च रिजल्ट्स एंड
सेव देम इन ए फाइल बेसिकली क्या करते हैं
जितने भी आप क्वेरी सर्च करते हो रिलेटेड
टू
योर क्यूरी रिलेटेड टू जो जो भी आपका
क्यूरी बोल सकते हो या जो भी आपका जो
इंफॉर्मेशन है या जो भी डोमेन से रिलेटेड
जो भी क्यूरी आप क्या करते हो सर्च करते
हो अगर आप उसको क्या करना चाहते हो
स्क्रीन पर देखने की बजाय आप किसी भी एक
फाइल के अंदर स्टोर करना चाहते हो तो वो
आप बहुत ही आसानी से स्टोर कर सकते हो विद
द हेल्प ऑफ सडन सील आई बट ये क्या करता है
किस फॉर्मेट में स्टोर करता है एक जेसन
फॉर्मेट में किस फॉर्मेट में स्टोर करता
है ये जेसन फॉर्मेट में सारी की सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन स्टोर करता है कैसे कि फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं अभी बात करता हूं ये रहा
कि मैं बात करहा हूं सडन कैसे यूज करना है
सडन उसके बाद
डाउनलोड सडन डाउनलोड यही है शो डान
डाउनलोड देन उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे नेम
ऑफ द फाइल मैं एक बार आपको टैग बताता हूं
यहां पर क्या है नेम ऑफ द फाइल यहां लिखे
नेम फाइल का नाम क्या रखना चाहता हूं मैं
ओपन
एसएसए फाइल ओपन एसएसएस फाइल रखना चाहता
हूं उसका नाम उसके बाद आपको क्या रखना है
सर्च क्यूरी जिसको आप क्या करना चाहते हो
सर्च करना चाहते हो ओपन एसएसए ए तो मैं
आपको एक बार दिखा देता हूं कि देखो सडन है
ये टूल्स का नाम आपका डाउनलोड ये ऑप्शंस
आप यूज कर रहे हो या फिल्टर यूज कर रहे हो
ये उस फाइल का नाम है जिस फाइल के अंदर आप
उस आउटपुट को सेव करना चाहते हो देन उसके
बाद ओपन एसएसएस ये क्या है मेरी सर्च
क्यूरी है और जैसे ही मैं सिंपली एंटर
करूंगा ये देखिए हिट एंटर इट विल टेक टाइम
बट यह क्या करेगा एक जिप फॉर्मेट में उस
फाइल को क्या कर दिया देखो क्यूरी क्रेडिट
लेफ्ट 100
और अभी क्या है इट विल आउटपुट फाइल क्या
है मेरी आउटपुट फाइल का नाम क्या रहेगा
ओपन एस फाड जनजी जड मतलब जिप फ में फम में
उसको क्या करर स्टोर कर रहा है 20 पर हो
गया है विदन न मिनट और 30 सेकंड में क्या
कंप्लीट जो मेरा आउटपुट है उसको एक फाइल
के अंदर स्टोर कर देगा जिप फॉर्म में
गेटिंग माय पट जो आपको समझाने की कोशिश कर
रहा हूं सबको समझ में आ रहा है
ओके और इसने क्या जो 1000 रिजल्ट थे उसको
क्या कर दिया एक ओपनस फाइल के अंदर स्टोर
कर दिया ओनली 1000 रिजल्ट रिजल्ट को ही
स्टोर करे था ओके और इसको आप क्या कर सकते
हो लिमिट भी कर सकते हो ओके ओनली 1000
रिजल्ट को ही करे
चलो तो आगे मैं क्या करता एलस किया मैंने
और एलस करने के पर देखो ओपन ए फाड जनजी तो
अभी मैं इसको क्या करता हूं अनजिप करता हप
करने के लिए यूज करूंगा गनप गजप एक कमांड
होती है एक टूल होता है जिसकी हे से हम
क्या करते अजप कर सकते उसके बाद ओपन एसस
देन हिट एंटर देखिए देन उसके बाद एलस
लिस्टिंग उसके बाद य जसन फाइल है अभी मैं
इसको डायरेक्टली अगर ओपन करूंगा तो आपको
कुछ भी समझ में नहीं आया जैसे कैट किया
मैंने और ओपन एसएसए फाइल जसन डट हिट एंटर
देखिए ये जो भी आपको आउटपुट देखने को मिल
रहा है आपको समझ में नहीं आएगा या तो आप
उसको क्या करो किसी एक टेक्स्ट एडिटर के
द्वारा क्या करो उसको ओपन करो जैसे सबलान
टेक्स्ट एडिटर या कोई भी टेक्स्ट एडिटर
होगा जैसे कि मैं एक काम करता हूं इसको
ओपन करने की कोशिश करता हूं फाइल सिस्टम ओ
डबल
क्लिक ओके सब कुछ बहुत छोटा छोटा दिखाई दे
रहा है यार नो
इशू देन उसके बाद आई विल गो टू माय होम
डायरेक्टरी एंड दिस इज ओपन जसन फाइल एंड
ओपन
विद एंड विम के ओपन विद अदर एप्लीकेशन
माउस पैड मेरे पास सबलान टेक्स्ट एडिटर
नहीं है तो देन आई
विल आई विल ट्राई
विद माउस पैड वट टाइप ऑ रिजल्ट वी आर
सिंग ओके मोर बेटर पहले से अच्छे तरीके से
देखने को मिल रहा है देखिए मैं इसको जूम
कर देता हूं इस तरीके आपको आउटपुट देखने
को मिल रहा है
देखिए जूम कर रहा हूं सब कुछ जूम कर रहा
देखो इस तरीके से इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोटोकॉल
2.0 लाइसेंस की व्ट एवर इंफॉर्मेशन सस
इंफॉर्मेशन ओस नल टाइम स्टैंप है देन उसके
बाद टीसीपी दिस इ द आईपी एड्रेस एंड रीजन
दे लट ऑफ इनफर्मेशन
भर भर के इंफॉर्मेशन आपको उससे रिलेटेड
आपको देखने को मिल रही है किस टाइप की
एल्गोरिथम यूज की जा रही है की एल्गोरिथम
एंड दि आर लट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन देखिए हैश
वैल्यू आईपी एड्रेस मतलब सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको देखने को मिल रही है यह आपको क्या
बहुत ही आसानी आराम से बैठ के सारी फिल्डर
आउट करनी होगी देखने कौन सी आपके लिए
यूजफुल है कौन सी आपके लिए यूजफुल नहीं है
जैसे कंट्री नेम तो ओपन एसस से रिलेटेड
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन य पर देखने को मिल रही है
देन उसके बाद मैं अगर मैं इसको एक काम
करता हूं कि दूसरा अच्छा तरीका क्या है
कंट्रोल
ऑल एंड कंट्रोल सी अगर मैं इसको ओपन करता
हूं एक
मिनट एक और चीज है मैं इसको अगर अच्छे से
रिजल्ट को देखना चाहता हूं तो और भी अच्छा
तरीका है मैं एक बार इसको क्लोज कर देता
हूं क्लोज किया मैंने और मेरे पास एक
ब्राउजर है ब्राउजर में एक है वेबसाइट का
नाम ओपन करता हूं जिसका नाम
है ये
रहा जेसो
जसन ब्यूटीफायर
ओजी यह
रहा सस वन अभी मैं क्या करूंगा इस वाली जो
फाइल है इस कंप्लीट फाइल को मैं यहां पर
कट कॉपी पेस्ट करूंगा देखिए यहां पर इसको
मैं क्या करता अभी ओपन
विद अदर एप्लीकेशन माउस पैड ओपन
देन एटलीस्ट य 1000 रिजल्ट है मान के चल र
हो कि कितने होंगे ये 000 रिजल्ट्स है
1000 रिजल्ट है
नीट आप कोई भी यूज कर सकते हो फॉर एपल मैं
87 ही कर रहा हूं चलो अभी मैं 87 तक ही कर
रहा हूं क्योंकि बहुत ज्यादा है
कंट्रोल अभी मैं इसको क्या करता हूं कॉपी
देन उसके बाद मैं गो टू आवर ब्राउजर और
यहां पर मैं पेस्ट करता हूं यहां पर आप
क्या कर सकते
हो य रहा यह रहा इधर भी मैं इसको जूम कर
देता हूं यहां आपको बेटर देखने को मिलेगा
रिजल्ट उसी तरीके से आपको य बेटर तरीके से
मिलेगा देखिए इसको मैं क्या करता हूं
अभी टू टब भी दिखाता है ये नॉर्मली कोई
बात
नहीं यह
रहा यह फ इस तरीके से आपको इंफॉर्मेशन
देखने को मिलेगी
देखिए सोच देख रहे हो किस टाइप की
इंफॉर्मेशन इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोटोकॉल 2.0
प्रोडक्ट क्या है लिंक सस मोडिफाय ड्रॉप
एसस एचडी सस इंफॉर्मेशन
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है
टाइम स्टैंप यह है आईएसपी कैरेक्टर
क चार्टर कम्युनिकेशन आई एनसी ठीक है
ट्रांसपोर्ट टीसीपी आईपी 98 12329 103
सोडा रीजन नॉट एप्लीकेबल पॉइंटर ट्रू
मॉड्यूल एसएसए है उसकी आईडी मेंशन की गई
है क्रॉलर उसके बाद दे लॉट ऑफ होस्ट नेम
इंफॉर्मेशन य देखो डोमेन नेम इंफॉर्मेशन
इज अवेलेबल एंड राउटर एडवा टाइ राउटर है
उसके बाद दे लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन आर अवेलेबल
यर ओके पोर्ट नंबर 22 है एंड एसएसए तो मैक
एड्रेस भी आपके पास मैक ओके नॉट अवेलेबल
दे लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन आर अवेलेबल ओके तो
इस तरीके से आप इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो नेक्स्ट अभी मैं कैसे यूज कर सकता
हूं चलो एक एक तरीका तो यह था दूसरा मैं
क्या करूंगा अभी इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता
हूं इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं क्लोज नाउ
देन उसके बाद और क्या कर सकता हूं मैं
उसके बाद मैं यूज कर सकता हूं एक होस्ट है
इसके अंदर मैं फिर से हेल्प फाइल खोलता
हूं क्लियर एक होस्ट फिल्टर होता
है ये
रहा एंड अभी एक और फिल्टर ये रहा होस्ट
होस्ट फिल्टर क्या करता है व्यू ऑल
अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन फॉर एन आईपी एड्रेस हम
क्या करते हैं यहां पर कोई भी अगर हमारे
पास कोई भी आईपी एड्रेस है अगर मुझे आईपी
एड्रेस से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करनी है होस्ट होस्ट
इंफॉर्मेशन होस्ट की इंफॉर्मेशन मेरे पास
आईपी एड्रेस है और उससे रिलेटेड मैं होस्ट
इंफ फाइंड आउट कर होस्ट एन्यूमरेशन कर रहा
हूं बेसिकली तो वो मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं
मेरे पास आईपी एड्रेस होना चाहिए तो मैं
कैसे करूंगा यह देखिए सिंपली अगर इस लेटेड
अगर आपको पता है कैसे यूज करना है इसको तो
आप ऐसे भी लिख सकते हो आईपी सडन होस्ट
उसके बाद हान एच भी कर सकते हो इसको मुझे
कैसे यूज करना है तो यह भी आपको देखने को
मिल जाएगा देखिए व्यू ऑल अवेलेबल
इंफॉर्मेशन फॉर एन आईपी एड्रेस इस तरीके
यूज करना होस्ट ऑप्शन आईपी एड्रेस ओके
ऑप्शन कौन सा फॉर्मेट यूज कर सकते हो फाइल
नेम टी एक्सटी सेव एच ये सारे ऑप्शन आप
इसके साथ यूज कर सकते हो लेकिन मैं क्या
सिंपल यूज करने वाला हूं फॉर एग्जांपल
सडन होस्ट और मैं क्या करना करने वाला हूं
डीएनएस इंफॉर्मेशन यूज कर रहा हूं फॉर
एग्जांपल
8.8 अरे व्हाट
हैपन
चलो
सॉरी स डान
होस्ट
8.8.8 ओके देन हिट
एंटर देखिए होस्ट इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने
को मिल रही है होस्ट नेम क्या है डीएनएस ग
का डीएनएस है सिटी माउंटेन व्यू कंट्री
यूनाइटेड स्टेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन ग एंड
अपडेटेड ऑन सोसो एंड नंबर ऑफ ओपन पोर्ट्स
टू 53 एंड 443 पोर्ट्स आर ओपन उसका वर्जन
एंड कौन-कौन सी एल वर्जन यूज कर रहा है
वर्जन 2 एसल वर्जन 3 लस वर्जन 1 1.1 1.2
एंड 1.3 ल दिस इंफॉर्मेशन इ इ यूजिंग तो
इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो पर्टिकुलर
आईपी एड्रेस के थ्रू होस्ट इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो कैसे
फॉर एग्जांपल मैं क्या करता हूं पिन करता
हूं
और github.com किया
मैंने अभी जब मैंने उसको गट किया कंट्रोल
सी इसको किया अभी यहां पर गिट का आईपी
एड्रेस आ गया मेरे पास ये रहा चलो
सिलेक्शन एंड अभी मैं क्या करता हूं य रहा
इधर पेस्ट कर देता हूं कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व
हिट एंटर
देखिए यह रहा गट up.com
ww.com सिटी पुणे कंट्री इंडिया
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट कॉर्पोरेशन अपडेटेड ऑन नंबर
ऑ पो ओपन 22 80 एंड 443 ल दिस इंफॉर्मेशन
इज अवेलेबल
यस अब्दुल सरंग ऑल द इंफॉर्मेशन वच इज
अवेलेबल इन द डेटाबेस ओपन एसएस रिलेटेड
ओनली 1000 क्यूरीज ही इसने स्टोर किया
उसके सामने जबकि आप क्या है उसके रिजल्ट्स
थे 53000 लेकिन ओनली 1000 क्यूरी को ही
उसने स्टोर किया
है ना उसके बाद हम बात करते हैं सूडान में
नेक्स्ट जो फिल्टर मैं यूज करने वाला हूं
उसका नाम है पार्स उसका नाम क्या है पार्स
देखिए
हेल्प फाइल को मैं फिर से ओपन करता हूं यह
रहा यह
र नाउ अभी जो मेरा नेक्स्ट फिल्टर है मेरा
यह पारस यह रहा एक्स्टेक्स्ट इंफॉर्मेशन
आउट ऑफ कंप्रेस जेसन फाइल्स देखो लास्ट
टाइम हमने क्या किया जब डाउनलोड डाउनलोड
फिल्टर को यूज किया था हमने क्या किया
किसी भी एक सर्च क्यूरी के आउटपुट को हमने
क्या किया रिजल्ट को क्या किया एक कंप्रेस
जेसन फाइल में हमने क्या किया उसमें स्टोर
किया था लेकिन अगर मुझे उसको क्या करना है
कि इधर टर्मिनल के अंदर ही विद द हेल्प ऑफ
सडन भी मैं उसको क्या कर सकता हूं रीड आउट
कर सकता हूं एक वेरी गुड ह्यूमन रीडेबल
फॉर्म में मतलब एक अच्छे अरेंज वे में तो
वो भी एक तरीका है तो वो हम कैसे कर सकते
हैं फॉर एग्जांपल मैं इसको कैसे यू कर
सकता हूं शोडाउन उसके बाद पार्स पार्स देन
उसके बाद मैं फाइल का नाम मैं रखता हूं
कौन सी जो मेरी
अ कौन सी फाइल थी ओपन एसएसएस की फाइल थी
ये
रहा ओन एए फाड हिट एंटर देखिए
अभी मैं इसके रिजल्ट को यहां पर ऐसे भी
देख सकता हूं देखिए ध्यान से बिल्कुल यह
रहा देखोगे अगर तो इस तरीके से एक अरेंज
वे में य काफी अ उस तरीके से जैसे बेटर
तरीके से है यह देखो आईपी एड्रेस
पोर्ट देल और अदर इंफॉर्मेशन मतलब
स्टार्टिंग से देखना हो एक बार बट यह 000
पोर्ट्स है तो एक बार हम चलते हैं
स्टार्टिंग
में तो उस इंफॉर्मेशन आप क्या है पार्स
कमांड की हेल्प से भी अच्छे से देख सकते
हो यह
देखो पार्स देखो आईपी एड्रेस पोर्ट नंबर
22 क्योंकि ओपन एसएसएस है एसएसएस वर्जन
2.0 है देन उसका ये क्या है डोमेन नेम और
उससे रिलेटेड क्या है की आपको देखने को
मिल रही है देन उसके बाद नेक्स्ट आईपी
एड्रेस पोर्ट नंबर उसका वर्जन ओपन एसस की
यह रखी देन उसके बाद इज इट वर्नेल नॉट
वर्नेल ये आपको ट्राई करना होगा देखना
होगा बट यह जो इंफॉर्मेशन इसके डेटाबेस
में सारी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन इसने शो कर दी
ओपन एसस से
रिलेटेड नो आप फ्री में यूज नहीं कर पाओगे
कुलदीप पटेल ओके तो अभी मैं क्या करता हूं
कंट्रोल सी एंड क्लियर कर देता हूं आउटपुट
नेक्स्ट जो फिल्टर हम यूज कर सकते हैं वह
हमारा सर्च फिल्टर कौन सा फिल्टर हम यूज
कर सकते हैं सर्च फिल्टर सन फिर से मैं
आपको हेल्प दिखा देता हूं हाइन हान हेल्प
यह रहा सर्च फिल्टर य रहा सर्च फिल्टर
क्या करता है सर्च द सडन डेटाबेस सर्च द
सडन डेटाबेस अभी भी वही काम कर लेकिन क्या
कि अभी डेटाबेस के अंदर हम पर्टिकुलर उस
चीज को सर्च कर सकते हैं कैसे कर सकते हैं
फॉर एपल अभी मैं क्या कर रहा हूं ी एक
अरेंज वे में आपके टर्मिनल पर आउटपुट में
शो करेगा
कैसे शोडाउन हा शोडाउन
सर्च सर्च देन उसके बाद मैं क्या कर
एग्जांपल मैं यूज कर रहा हूं एसएसए ट
एंटर
देखिए वही चीज है सेम वे में जिस तरीके से
आपको इंफो देखने को मिल थी ये रहा देखो यह
रहा आईपी एड्रेस पोर्ट नंबर डोमेन या सब
डोमेन नेम ओपन एसएसएस 99.0 नटू देखो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का नाम भी आ गया देन उसके
बाद और भी अदर इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को
मिल रही है एल्गोरिदम की इंफॉर्मेशन है
सा 250 सा 512 इंफॉर्मेशन ओके देन य रट
नेक्स्ट देखिए इस तर से आपको इंफॉर्मेशन
देखने को मिल रही है आप इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट कर सकते हो सिंपली य पर क्विट किया तो
यह यहां पर क्लोज हो
गया तो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो
सर्च फिल्टर को भी यूज कर सकते हो नेक्स्ट
जो आप फिल्टर यूज कर सकते हो वो क्या आपका
स्कैन नेक्स्ट फिल्टर यूज कर सकते हो
स्कैन देखिए स्कैन फिल्टर क्या करता है
स्कैन एन आईपी या नेट यूजिंग सडन आप क्या
कर सकते हो किसी भी एक आईपी एड्रेस को या
पूरी सिडा रेंज मतलब उसकी जो रेंज है उसका
जो सबनेट पूरे उस ब्लॉक को भी क्या कर
सकते हो स्कैन कर सकते हो फर एपल मुझे किस
आईपी एड्रेस को स्कैन करना है मैं अगर चेक
करूं अगर तो वह है मैं फॉर एग्जांपल व्ट
विल बी आईपी
एड्रेस एनी
वन नहीं करेक्ट नहीं हुआ अभी तक तो किसी
ने किया है
अगर आपके पास स्किल है तो यू कैन डू इट की
उसको जेसन को कैट करके और उसके बाद जे
क्यू करके कर सकते
हो नहीं सीख सकते कुलदीप उसको इंडस्ट्री
में उसको यूज किया जाता है और इंडस्ट्री
वाले आपको जब आप एज पेटर हायर किया जाओगे
तो वहां पर सार ट पे टूल भी आपको फ्री
मिलते हैं ओके नेक्स्ट आप क्या यूज कर
सकते हो स्न कर सकते फॉर एपल मैं आईपी
एड्रेस स्कैन करने की कोशिश करता हूं च वन
मैं इफ कन्फी करता
हूं ये रहा फफ क दिस इ माय आईपी एड्रेस
चलो कॉपी सिलेक्शन किया अब मैं क्या कर
सकता
हूं सो डान उसके बाद मैं क्या करता
हूं स्कैन उसके बाद मैं एक बार हान एस
दिखा देता आपको देखो तो इसकी भी एक हेल्प
मेनू है ये क्या करता स्कैन एन आईपी एंड
नेट ब्लॉक यूजिंग सडन देखिए आप उसके साथ
कौन-कौन सी कमांड यूज कर सकते हो कमांड
में इंटरनेट मतलब स्कैन द इंटरनेट फॉर ए
स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट एंड प्रोटोकॉल यूजिंग द
अगर आप क्या चाहते हो कि पूरे इंटरनेट पर
कुछ एक स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट या प्रोटोकॉल को
इस स्कैन करना चाहते हैं तो वो भी आप कर
सकते हो पर्टिकुलर आईपी पे या आप क्या
करना चाहते हो अ लिस्ट आउट कर सकते हैं
रिसेंटली स्कैन वो भी देख सकते हो अगर आप
रिसेंटली स्कैन किया हो य इस आईपी एड्रेस
के तो उसके उसकी अगर हिस्ट्री को देखना
चाहते हैं या उसके स्कैन को देखना चाहते
वो भी शो कर देगा प्रोटोकॉल मतलब लिस्ट द
प्रोटोकॉल दैट यू कैन स्कन विद द अगर आप
किसी पर्टिकुलर स्पेसिफिक प्रोटोकॉल को
स्कैन करना चाहते हो सडन की हेल्प से वो
भी कर सकते हो अगर आप स्टेटस चेक करना
चाहते हो स्कैन का वो भी चेक कर सकते हो
दूसरा सबमिट स्कैन एन आईपी और नेट ब्लॉक
यूजिंग सडन तो मैं क्या करता आईपी नेट
ब्लॉक यूज करने के लिए मैं क्या कर सडन
स्कैन
सबमिट सबमिट उसके बाद कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व एंड
हिट एंटर कर देता हूं देखिए अभी मैं ये
मेरा क्या स्कैन रिजल्ट एक कम हो जाएगा
प्राइवेट आईपी इ नॉट अलाउड ओके प्राइवेट
आईपी अलाउड नहीं है आपको क्या करना होगा
कोई पब्लिक आईपी देना होगा पब्लिक आईपी
फॉर एग्जांपल मुझे उसकी परमिशन चाहिए होगी
तो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो सोडास
कैन सबमिट यहां पर कोई भी पब्लिक आईपी
आपको प्रोवाइड करना होगा अभी मेरे पास
क्या है पब्लिक आईपी नहीं
है देखो कुलदीप अल्टरनेट ऑप्शन जो
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको डान प्रोवाइड करता है वो
आपको मैनुअल या दो मैनुअल तरीके से ट्राई
कर सकते हो googlegroups.com
तो आपको उसमें ज्यादा मेहनत करनी
पड़ेगी यह मैं आपको सिखा रहा हूं बस मुझे
पता है कि आप इसकी प्रैक्टिस नहीं कर
पाओगे लेकिन आप लोग देखिए और समझनी कि
क्याक चीजें हो रही है क्याक चीजें हो
सकती है सडन को कैसे यूज किया सकता है
क्योंकि ऐसा कोई भी मेरे ख्याल से इंटरनेट
प इधर अभी ू पर ट्यूटोरियल अवेलेबल नहीं
है सडन से रिलेटेड ओके नाउ उसके बाद हम
क्या कर सकते हैं कि एक और चीज है स्कैन
के अलावा फिर से हेल्प मेनू ओपन करता हूं
सडन हाइन हाइन
हेल्प ओके अभी जो नेक्स्ट है हमारे पास है
स्टेट्स स्टेट्स स्टेट्स अभ ये क्या करता
प्रोवाइड द समरी इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट ए सर्च
क्यूरी ओके ये क्या करता है जो भी सर्च
क्यूरी उससे रिलेटेड एक समरी एक रिपोर्ट
टाइप से आपके सामने शो करता है फॉर
एग्जांपल इसका मैं एक दिखाता हूं शान हाइन
मतलब स्टेट स्टेट्स देन मैं सर्च कर रहा
हूं एफटीपी एफटीपी मैंने सर्च किया देखिए
अभ इस रिलेटेड क्या इंफॉर्मेशन आपको शो कर
रहा है ये देखिए यह आपको बता रहा है कि
देखो जो एफटीपी है टॉप 10 रिजल्ट बता है
कि य प्रोवाइड द इंफॉर्मेशन ऑफ एफटीपी
सर्वर चच इज बिलोंग टू दिस पर्टिकुलर मतलब
सबसे ज्यादा देखो
सीएन इतने ज्यादा एफटीपी सर्वर्स का डाटा
अवेलेबल है इसके पास सडन का उसके बाद
सेकंड मोस्ट यूएस थर्ड डीई फ जापान में भी
पाकिस्तान इंडिया इंडिया में कितने एफटीपी
इनेबल है इतने
10136 उसके बाद टॉप 10 रिजल्ट ऑफ
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन टॉप 10 रिजल्ट ऑफ एन
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन हु इज हैंडलिंग एफटीपी जैसे
11 इतने एफटीपी इस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन से देन
होस्ट यूरोप एन चाइना यूनिकॉर्न सर्वर
मेनिया दज आर द लिस्ट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन
अवेलेबल रिलेटेड टू द एफटीपी तो सारे
एफटीपी की इंफॉर्मेशन रिलेटेड टू कंट्री
स्पेसिफिक और रिलेटेड टू ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
स्पेसिफिक
नेक्स्ट एक और इसके
[संगीत]
अंदर य भी अभी एक सब डोमेन एमेशन करना है
फर एपल मुझे डोमेन की इंफॉर्मेशन लेनी है
तो मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं सोडा हाइ
फन हाइन हाइन
हेल्प
य अभी डोमेन य रहा व्यू ऑल अवेलेबल
इंफॉर्मेशन फॉर ए पर्टिकुलर डोमेन अभी मैं
डोमेन के रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आट कर
तो
सडन डोमेन देन मैं अपने डोमेन की बात करते
हैं
हम फक्ड कॉम ओके
यहा यह आपके पास रिपोर्ट रिकॉर्ड बताएगा
दिस इ द मेन डोमेन य रिकॉर्ड एमस रिकॉर्ड
नेम सर्वर रिकॉर्ड सो रिकॉर्ड टी एक्सटी
रिकर्ड ए दे लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन सी नेम
रिकॉर्ड्स फिर से ए रिकॉर्ड अकॉर्डिंग टू
आईपी एड्रेस आईपी एड्रेस ए रिकॉर्ड्स
अकॉर्डिंग टू आई एडस दे लट ऑफ इ इट
प्रोवाइड द रिलेटेड टू द पर्टिकुलर डोमेन
ओके तो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सते डोमेन
सब डोमेन की इंफॉर्मेशन भी से फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो क्योंकि अभी डिफ
के पास ओनली एक ही डोमेन है तो उस टेड
इंफॉर्मेशन अगर मैं एक और इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करू जैसे
की एमसन करते एमसन msn.com
देखिए दे लट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन रिलेटेड टू द
एसन कॉ दे देखिए यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा यह
रहा इतने सारे आईपी एड्रेस अवेलेबल है और
इतनी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है रिलेटेड
टू द एमएस देखिए मे भी बहुत ज्यादा
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है इसके सी नेम
रिकॉर्ड्स है
डोमेन सब डोमेन वट इंफॉर्मेशन रिलेटेड टू
दिस एमएस एन कॉ यह सारी सारी इसके डेटाबेस
से सर्च करता और आपके सामने शो कर देता
है देखिए म काफी ज्यादा रिजल्ट्स है तो जो
स्क्रोल डाउन करने में थोड़ी सी प्रॉब्लम
आ रही है तो नाउ गो बैक ट अवर टॉपिक चलो
अभी यह तो था आपका सील आई वर्जन इसका एक
और है मैं को एक एक टूल्स और है इसके लिए
मैं कंट्रोल क्य क्यू
ओके अगर आप अपनी प्रोसेस को ऑटोमेट करना
चाहते हो तो वह भी कर सकते हो कैसे फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी मैं
इसको मिनिमाइज कर देता हूं देन ओपन आवर
ब्राउजर देन दे इज अ टूल
नेम हम हम
हम यह रहा एक टूल का नाम है हम यूज करेंगे
जो है उसका नाम है
सो डोमेन य
रहा गिट अप प होगा सो डोमेन यह रहा सोमिया
92 स
डोमेन यह रहा एक गिट अप टूल्स अवेलेबल है
जिसको भी हम क्या कर सकते हैं सब डोमेन
एन्यूमरेशन के लिए यूज कर सकते हो तो
सिंपली आपको इस टूल को कैसे इंस्टॉल करना
है आपको गिट क्लन करना है गो टू टू कोड
एंड कॉपी टू क्लिपबोर्ड देन गो टू र
टर्मिनल च वन वी आर गोइंग
नो वि दिस वन आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
क्लियर योर स्क्रीन देन हम क्या करेंगे
गिट
क्लोन एंड कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व एंटर अभी
सक्सेसफुली मेरे पास क्या है कि मैंने
इसको इंस्टॉल कर रखा है तो इसलिए क्या है
कि यहां पर क्या ऑलरेडी एजिस्ट करता है
लेकिन के केस में क्या हो गया इसके
अगेंस्ट एक 100 डोमेन नाम से एक
डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट हो जाएगी तो जब मैं े
ओपन करूंगा तो ये रहा 100 डोमेन नाम की
देन सीडी करना चन डायरेक्टरी एंड शो डोमेन
हिट एंटर एलएस देन उसके बाद आपको सिंपली
नेक्स्ट कमांड जो आपको रन करनी है वो आपको
क्या करनी है पाइथन 3 हाइन आर उसके बाद
नहीं पाइथन 3 देन ओके
नहीं नहीं इसमें करने की जरूरत नहीं है
ऑलरेडी सब डोमेन रिक्वायरमेंट एक् फाइल आप
कर सकते हो
लेकिन ओके ओके
ओके पिप इंस्टॉल करना आपको पिप इंस्टॉल
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है हाइन आर रन
करना है और इसमें जो रिक्वायरमेंट टी
एक्सटी फाइल है उसको क्या करना है रन करना
है टी एक्सटी हिट एंटर कर देना है तो मेरे
में ऑलरेडी सेटिस्फाइड है तो कुछ भी होगा
नहीं लेकिन आप उसके बाद रन करने के लिए
पाइथन देन उसके बाद आपको इसको यूज करना है
स डोमेन डट पाई हाइन हाइन हेल्प आपको यूज
करना है आप इस तरीके से यूज कर सकते हो
अगर आपको इसको यूज करना है तो आप सिंपली
यूज
करोगे स डोमेन डॉट पाई उसके बाद आपको
एपीआई की यूज करनी है आपके सडन की देन
उसके बाद डोमेन आईडी अब मैं क्या करता हूं
जैसे कि फॉर एग्जांपल हम यूज करते हैं
को टोलर मैंने किया
[संगीत]
था मैं अभी आपको एपीआई की शो नहीं कर सकता
लेकिन उसकी य यूसेज यही है आपको यूसेज शो
करने के लिए मैं इसको ऑफ नहीं कर सकता बट
मे बी आई विल
ओके तो इस तरीके से आप इसको क्या कर सकते
हो टूल को यूज कर सकते हो मैं आपको बताया
था
सिंपली आपको क्या करना है सडन ड पाई एपीआई
की देन उसके बाद डोमेन और य आपके सामने जो
जो भी सब डोमेन है उनकी लिस्ट फाइंड आउट
करके आपके स्क्रीन के सामने शो कर
देगा यस इट ओनली रिक्वायर्ड एपीआई
की तो एक ऑटोमेशन वे है एक ऑटोमेशन तरीका
था और दूसरा हम क्या कर सकते हैं एक और
चीज है इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं अभी
अभी के लिए देन दिस इ क्लोज एंड एक और चीज
है य सडन सर्च इंजन है अभी य पर बोर्ड
अवेलेबल है डैशबोर्ड पर आप क्या कर सकते
हो इसमें इसके पास और भी है एक इमेज इमेज
सर्च इंजन होता है और एक इसके पास
एक्सप्लो सर्च इंजन भी है अब इमेज सर्च
इंजन में क्या करता है कि यहां पर जब यह
क्रॉल करता है क्रॉल करते वक्त किसी भी
डिवाइस के अगर अनसिक्योर टी की वजह किसी
भी कारण से अगर कोई भी स्क्रीनशॉट अगर ले
पाता तो इसके पास वो सारे स्क्रीनशॉट क्या
करते इसके डेटाबेस में स्टोर हो जाते हैं
तो आप क्या कर सकते हो किसी भी पर्टिकुलर
जो टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है उस उस टारगेट
से रिलेटेड आप क्या कर सकते हो स्क्रीनशॉट
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो अगर
उसका कोई स्क्रीनशॉट मिलता है तो
स्क्रीनशॉट पे आप फिर अगर उसके अंदर
वल्नरेबल है या नहीं है या उसको आप एक्सेस
कर पाओगे नहीं कर पाओगे व सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
आप क्या कर सकते हो ट्राई कर सकते हो तो
जैसे कि कहां पर अवेलेबल है ब्राउज इमेज
देखिए कहीं से नहीं मिलेगा
एपीआई तो अभी यहां पर देखो बाय डिफॉल्ट
देर लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन आ अवेलेबल जैसे कि
मैं यहां पर क्लिक करता हूं जैसे कि
स्क्रीनशॉट अवेलेबल
है इट विल टेक टाइम देखिए यह
एक जिसका आईपी
एड्रेस नॉट अवेलेबल दिस इज आईपी एड्रेस
21.256600
का आईपी एड्रेस है एंड इसका जो पोर्ट है
3389 मतलब एक आरडीपी रिमोट डेस्ट
प्रोटोकॉल मतलब क्या है कि अगर यह जब सडन
ने इसको क्रॉल किया क्रॉल करते वक्त अगर
यह क्या है कि सही से कंफिल नहीं है या
अभी भी इसको सही से कंफिल नहीं किया या
इसके जो क्रेडेंशियल है डिफॉल्ट
क्रेडेंशियल हैं अभी तक क्रेडेंशियल को
चेंज नहीं किया गया या इसके जो भी बोल
सकते हो कि जो पासवर्ड है वो डिफॉल्ट
पासवर्ड है अगर वो अभी भी सेम है तो आप
क्या कर सकते हो इसको एक्सेस कर सकते हो
और उसको यूज कर सकते हो तो रमो डेक्स
प्रोटोकॉल जिसके अंदर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कौन
सा है विंड सर्वर
2022 ओस बिल 10.0 है टारगेट नेम यह है नेट
वॉइस डोमेन नेम यह है नेट बॉय कंप्यूटर
नेम य दे लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन आर अवेलेबल
रिलेटेड टू दिस आईपी एड्रेस एंड यू कैन
ट्राई इट इसके ऊपर आप ट्राई कर सकते हो बट
आई विल रिकमेंड डोंट ट्राई इट विदाउट
प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन और विदाउट प्रॉपर
परमिशन तो इस तरीके से क्या कर सकते हो आप
अपने टारगेट रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन सर्च जैसे
डेनिक रिलेटेड अगर मैं इसमें सर्च करता
हूं इमेज के अंदर मे बी दिस विल बी
इमेज तो मैं अगर सर्च मारूं तो
देखिए
एंड इधर चलो इमेज नहीं है नो रिजल्ट इज
फाउंड अदर वाइज यह रहा इमेज सर्च इंजन
यहां पर
है नो रिजल्ट इ फ मतलब यहां पर कोई भी
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल नहीं है इससे रिलेटेड
दूसरा क्या होता है एक और चीज है कि इसके
अंदर सडन एक्सप्लोइट्स इसका जो हम ये रहा
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल
https.com आपको क्या करना है यह रहा डोमेन
जो मैंने हाईलाइट किया आपके
सामने कॉपी किया और यहां पर मैं पेस्ट कर
देता हूं एक बार पेस्ट किया यह वाला डोमेन
है
https.com आपको सिंपली इसको क्या करना है
जब आप आपके पास अगर क्रेडिट अवेलेबल है
अगर आपके पास एपीआई की मिलती है आपको कोई
परमिशन देता है तो सिंपली क्या करना है
इसको आपको सर्च करना है क्यूरी के अंदर
उसके बाद इस तरीके आपका सामने सर्च इंजन
होगा अब यह क्या करता है यहां पर क्या है
जितने भी एक्सप्लोइट्स अवेलेबल है किसी भी
सर्विस से रिलेटेड किसी भी सर्वर से
रिलेटेड जितने चाहे विज
[संगीत]
अंदर है अगर ड्यूरिंग इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
आपको चाहे वो एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
या पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग है चाहे आप
सिस्टम हैकिंग ही क्यों ना कर रहे हो तो
उस टाइम पे अगर कोई भी एक ऐसी स्पेसिफिक
सर्विस आपको देखने को मिलती है कोई भी
वर्जन देखने को मिलता तो अगर आपको वर्जन
स्पेसिफिक एक्सप्ले फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करनी है तो आप यहां पे भी फाइंड आउट
कर सकते हो वैसे तो
क्या आप यहां पर भी फाइंड आउट कर फॉर
एग्जांपल अचे चे जो वेब सर्वर है उससे
रिलेटेड अगर इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करनी है
तो सिंपली यहां पर सर्च कीजिए ये आपके
सामने जितने भी एक्सप्लोइट रिलेटेड टू अचे
वेब सर्वर फॉर एग्जांपल दे आर टोटल 83
रिजल्ट्स जो जहां पर एक्सप्लोर डीबी से
838 लिए हैं मेटा स्ट से 15 मॉड्यूल आर
अवेलेबल प्लेटफॉर्म कौन-कौन से हैं पीएचपी
एक्सप्लोइट्स आर अवेलेबल आप सिंपली यहां
पर क्लिक करोगे जैसे मैंने यहां पर क्लिक
किया सीएमएस 0.4 कंटेंट मैनेजमेंट एंड दिस
इज द
एक्सप्लोइट और इस एक्सप्लोइट को आप क्या
कर सकते हो अपने मशीन को अटैक करने के लिए
आपके टारगेट को अटैक करने के लिए यूज कर
सकते हो अगर यह वलन बिलिटी होगी तो
एक्सप्लोइट हो जाएगी अगर यह वनटी पैच हो
गई होगी तो सॉरी फॉर दैट आप उसको
एक्सप्लोइट नहीं कर पाओगे वलने बिलिटी को
फाइंड आउट नहीं कर पाओगे या उसको अटैक
नहीं कर पाओगे तो यह सारी सारी फॉर्मेशन
अवेलेबल थी रिलेटेड टू सडन और आई थिंक की
आई एक्सप्लेन वेरी ब्रीफ रिलेटेड टू सडन
तो उसके बाद नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम सडन के
ऊपर डिस्कस नहीं करेंगे नेक्स्ट क्लास में
हम फर्द जैसे कि सर्टिफिकेट ट्रांसपेरेंसी
रह गई पे बैक यूआरएल हो गए सीएमएस
आइडेंटिफिकेशन कैसे करेंगे दे और भी जो
चीजें बच गई है रिलेटेड टू पैसिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग वेब सर्विसेस के थ्रू
नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम वो डिस्कस करेंगे तो
नेक्स्ट क्लास टोटली प्रैक्टिकल्स होगी आई
विल ट्राई कि आपके उसमें
कोई भी स्लाइड ना हो जैसे कि बेसिकली
रिलेटेड टू नेक्स्ट टॉपिक तो यहां पर क्या
है कि ओनली प्रैक्टिकल ही करेंगे नेक्स्ट
क्लास में उसके बाद नेक्स्ट में रहेगा तो
आई विल 90 पर प्रैक्टिकल
रहेगा तो अगर कांसेप्ट रिलेटेड कोई भी
किसी के कोई भी डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ सकता
है अभी पा मिनट के लिए अवेलेबल उसके बाद
हम सेशन को एंड करेंगे
स और नोट्स मिल जाएंगे आपके
उसमें कमेंट कर सकते होग जो भी आपका
डिटेल्स डाउट है आप नाम स्पेसिफाई कीजिए
उस डाउट को उसके अंदर मेंशन कीजिए और जैसे
नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी उस नेक्स्ट क्लास में
हम क्या करेंगे उस डाउट को क्लियर करेंगे
उसके बाद फर्द सेशन स्टार्ट
करेंगे दिस इज द रोड मैप
आज का कोई टास्क नहीं
है ओके सेशन को एंड करते हैं अगर फिर भी
आपके कोई डाउट्स है तो आप क्या करना इस
वीडियो खत्म होने के बाद जो भी कमेंट
सेक्शन है उसमें अपना डाउट मेंशन कर दीजिए
नेक्स्ट क्लास में उसपे हम डिस्कस
करेंगे तोके बाय बाय टेक केयर एंड सी यू
फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन जल्दी मिलेंगे